est un budget qui avec les crédits du
plan de relance son crédit du plf plus
crédits du plan de relance qui sont je
le rappelle ce temps de relance dans
deux programmes particuliers de 363 360
de bien aborder de manière extrêmement
forte les crédits du ministère de
l'intérieur puisque ces crédits vont
donc augmenté d'un milliard 140 millions
ce chiffre d'ailleurs jeudi dans la
commission des lois du sénat est
supérieur aux daims archives que j'ai pu
communiquer publiquement notamment
devant vos collègues de l'assemblée
nationale puisque le chiffre de la
semaine nationale était de 1 milliard 15
millions mais entre temps dans le plan
de relance ont été acceptés les
hélicoptères du plan de relance
aéronautique au fil du ministère de
l'intérieur
et donc c'est bien un milliard cent
quarante millions de crédits du plf
supplémentaires par rapport à la base
des crédits du ministère de l'intérieur
qui seront dans le budget de 2021
je voudrais leur dire que pour l'avoir
vu du côté du ministère des contrats
publics pendant trois ans sous
l'autorité du premier ministre edouard
philippe que je remercie et sous
l'autorité de jean castex remise
intérieure que je remercie également
hors casse nous sommes à 2 7 milliards
d'augmentation des crédits depuis que le
président de la république et emmanuel
macron pour le ministère de l'intérieur
ce qui montre la priorité importante
même si l'augmentation des crédits
budgétaires n'est pas toujours synonyme
de priorité ou d'efficacité politique
jeu j'espère avec ministre que
l'augmentation des crédits budgétaires
veut aussi dire efficacité et priorités
politiques pour le ministère de
l'intérieur
peut-être trois points vont donner la
parole à madame la ministre déléguée sur
les sujets qui la concernent notamment
sur le sujet très important de
l'immigration et de l'asile et
d'intégration rappelé les trois
ambitions fortes que nous nous sommes
fixés 1120 d'ailleurs en arrivant en
responsabilité début du mois de juillet
d'abord une lutte extrêmement forte
contre les stupéfiants
c'est la priorité du ministère de
l'intérieur et il mettre des moyens tant
en enquête qu'en matériel bien
évidemment mais bien sûr en hommes et en
femmes qui servent le ministère de
l'intérieur
ce sera l'une des priorités la création
des postes que
vous allez je l'espère nous accordé
conformément programme du président de
la république avec un renforcement très
fort de la sécurité publique et des
personnes qui tournent dans la
gendarmerie que dans la police vont
aider au travail autour de la lutte
contre les stupéfiants et notamment le
renforcement très forte de l'eau fast
vous savez cet office
ce sont deux des oeufs à la française
qui aide et je crois que les derniers
chiffres montrent avec efficacité le
travail contre le narco banditisme mais
aussi on le sait qu'ils responsable du
financement du terrorisme en partie de
la traite d'êtres humains et de manière
plus prosaïque dans le quotidien de
nombreux actes de délinquance
d'insécurité du quotidien des
cambriolages des occupations illicites
de halls d'immeubles des agressions
physiques des atteintes aux biens
viennent directement du trafic de
stupéfiants et nous pensent être la mère
de toutes les batailles
le deuxième sujet important ce jour
symbolique et la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes et aux
enfants de prise en appliquant a fait
une grande cause du quinquennat marlène
schiappa là beaucoup porté depuis début
du quinquennat dans d'autres fonctions
le porte encore auprès de mon ministère
de l'intérieur des moyens très
importants sont mis à disposition des
victimes mais aussi des policiers des
gens dans mon intervention je serai la
ministre en dire un mot évidemment s'ils
le souhaitent
après et enfin imposer les valeurs de la
république sur tout le territoire
national notamment lutte entre fortement
contre les dérives que le président de
la république a qualifié de séparatistes
mais de lutte contre l'islamisme radical
permettez moi de nous réjouir mais ce
président aujourd'hui un des décisions
du conseil d'état qui viennent confirmer
à la fois la fermeture de la mosquée de
pantin mais aussi la dissolution de
l'association baraka city j'aurai
l'occasion de proposer d'autres
dissolution dès la semaine prochaine au
conseil des ministres et le renforcement
des moyens mis à disposition des préfets
et des sous-préfets de la dgsi de l'état
en général
évidemment et est important dans le
cadre à la fois de prévision de tact qui
pourraient se poser pas simplement
d'actes terroristes de radicalisation
mais de séparation mais aussi de
prévention dans l'intégration
on aura l'occasion également d'en
reparler évidemment ces trois priorités
sont en plus de celles qui traversent
également la république depuis la fin du
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy fortement
porté par le
par le président hollande et par le
président macron qu'est la lutte contre
le terrorisme une augmentation constante
des moyens de la dgsi puisque vous
verrez l'année prochaine le doublement
depuis 2000 17 des effectifs de la dgsi
des moyens matériels mis à la
disposition et je crois dans un
humanisme ou d'un quasi unanime
humanisme politique
voilà je veux dire en quelques mots ces
sujets je laisser la parole à madame la
ministre si vous en êtes d'accord je
reviendrai sur les deux autres missions
l'homme présents mesdames et messieurs
l'été ça t la parole fut très heureuse
de pouvoir échanger avec vous et pouvoir
défendre côté admise à l'intérieur le
budget de la mission immigration asile
et intégration peut être en préambule
effectivement un mot une égard à ce jour
particulier puisque nous sommes le 25
novembre la journée internationale pour
l'élimination des violences à l'égard
des femmes et vous le savez puisque nous
avons eu l'occasion en trois ans de
débattre de trois lois qui ont toutes
été adoptées et qui viennent renforcer
considérablement les droits des femmes
face aux violences et le sénat a joué un
rôle très important dans ce renforcement
puisque les textes ont été
considérablement enrichie à chaque fois
lors de leur passage au sénat et c'est
très important pour nous et nous sommes
au ministère de l'intérieur en train de
mettre en oeuvre les dispositions qui
ont été votées dans ses lois qu'il
s'agisse du la généralisation de la
grille d'évaluation du danger des
dispositions de formation des policiers
des gendarmes tous désormais 120 heures
dans leur formation initiale plus des
formations continues pour faire face à
la manière de traiter mieux la prise de
plainte des femmes victimes de ces
violences nous avons souhaité renforcer
les moyens de la plateforme qui
s'appelle arrêtons les violences point
gouv.fr qui a été créée il ya près de
deux ans et qui permet aux femmes de
saisir les policiers les gendarmes 24
heures sur 24 et 7 jours sur 7 et avec
lui ni de l'intérieur nous avons
souhaité recruter 12 policiers
supplémentaires afin de pouvoir mieux
faire face aux 15% supplémentaires de
signalements qui étaient faits sur cette
plate forme depuis le début du deuxième
continent et ses douze policiers ils ont
tous été recrutés
les formations continues ont été lancés
donc ce sont des moyens
importants qui existent afin de
permettre aux policiers aux gendarmes de
remplir les objectifs que nous leur
avons donné et j'ai réuni ce matin
directeurs généraux de la police
nationale et la gendarmerie nationale
ainsi que les présidents de cour de
travail des grenelle des violences
conjugales
afin de re repartager renouveler notre
objectif qui est que de faire en sorte
que 100 % des plaintes soient prises
soient bien qualifiés et soient
transmises et donc je voudrais si vous
me le permettez bien évidemment salué
l'engagement des forces de l'ordre qui
tous les jours vont sauver la vie de
femmes et d'enfants en intervenant dans
les foyers lorsqu ils et elles sont
appelé à l'aide par des femmes qui sont
victimes de violences j'en reviens
maintenant au coeur de notre sujet des
crédits de la mission immigration asile
intégration ils sont vous savez
fortement mobilisés pour répondre à la
politique migratoire souhaité par le
prénom la république le premier ce musée
l'intérieur afin de faire en sorte que
ce soit une politique migratoire que
nous voulons maîtriser et équilibrée et
c'est un équilibre vous le savez qui
repose dans la droite ligne du président
la république depuis 2010 est sûre à la
fois envolés que nous avons volé de
l'humanité c'est à dire l'accueil et
l'intégration mais aussi sur la clarté
voir la fermeté vis-à-vis de celles et
ceux qui rentrent irrégulièrement sur le
territoire national et qui donc n'ont
pas vocation à y rester ou celles et
ceux qui se maintiennent bien que
déboutés de leur demande d'asile
je suis très attaché au fait que la
france souhaite une terre d'asile et que
si dans le monde des gens sont
persécutés g dans des territoires en
guerre ils peuvent venir en france et
demandé le statut de réfugié mais je
suis aussi très attaché
un siècle mise de l'intérieur au respect
des lois de la république et donc je
crois que cette obtention du statut de
réfugié elle ne se fait pas sans
contrepartie elle ne se fait pas de
manière éternelle et inconditionnelle et
nous avons déjà eu depuis notre entrée
en fonctions avec l'umih de l'intérieur
à prendre des décisions afin de faire
respecter les lois de la république et
nous le faisons dans ces cas là de façon
de façon très claire je crois que la
france doit être respectée dans ses
décisions et c'est ce que nous nous
attachons à faire les questions
d'immigration d'asie d'intégration vous
savez sont parmi les priorités du
ministère de l'intérieur et le projet de
loi de finances 2011 21 autorise une
augmentation des crédits de 36,8
millions d'euros ces 2 % de plus par
rapport à la loi de finances initiale de
2020 et donc je vais concentrer mon
intervention si vous voulez
véritablement sur le budget est
clairement sur celui ci
donc en complément de ces crédits nous
avons des crédits compétitivité de la
mission relance qui viennent abonder les
efforts budgétaires de la mission est là
ce sont 26,6 millions d'euros qui sont
mobilisés et qui viennent en crédits de
paiement compléter cet effort budgétaire
conséquent qui vise à nous donner les
moyens d'agir plus d'agir mieux via les
deux programmes de la mission le
programme 303 une migration et d'asile
et le programme 104 intégration et accès
à la nationalité française qui est aussi
un programme important est que nous
avons récemment beaucoup mobilisé j'y
reviendrai
d'abord sur le programme 303 voudrais
vous dire que ce programme il illustre
pour nous à la volonté résolue du
gouvernement de mieux accueillir mais
aussi de mieux lutter contre
l'immigration irrégulière et
particulièrement contre les filières
dites de passeurs qui mettent en danger
la vie de personnes en leur promettant
une vie meilleure dans un autre pays
alors que très souvent ils ne respectent
pas justement les aspirations unis même
la vie humaine de ces personnes donc
pour nous il est important d'abord de
nous concentrer sur les missions
d'accueil
les principales dépenses en matière
d'asile dans ce programme c'est donc
l'accueil et l'hébergement des
demandeurs d'asile on m'en parlait
précédemment
ils se traduisent par une hausse
significative du budget qui est consacré
à la dame à la location des demandeurs
d'asile que vous connaissez c'est une
hausse de 11,5 millions d'euros par
rapport à la loi de finances de 2011
jean et sa porte donc le budget à 459 4
millions d'euros je voudrais devant vous
messieurs les sénateurs mesdames les
sénatrices souligné cet effort qui
montre l'effort budgétaire de la nation
pour l'accueil des demandeurs d'asile
comme vous le savez parfaitement pour
avoir tous et tout si c'est beaucoup
travaillé sur ces questions
la demande d'asile elle ne peut pas être
chiffrée précisément à l'avance donc ce
que nous avons fait pour ces calculs
c'est que nous avons pris le parti de
retenir les chiffres de l'année 2019 qui
était une année exceptionnellement haute
en terme de demande et nous avons
souhaité pouvoir anticiper une réduction
progressive des délais de traitement de
la demande d'asile
suite à la mise en oeuvre de tous les
mécanismes sur lesquels on reviendra
peut-être si vous le souhaitez tout à
l'heure parce que nous estimons qu'elle
aura mécaniquement un effet sur la
baisse de la dépense
voilà en tout cas ce qu'a procédé à
notre calcul les actions que nous menons
cerf d'hébergement elles ont aussi un
effet mécanique là encore sur la dépense
consacrée à la dda donc ses actions pour
nous elle porte sur la fluidité du parc
d'hébergement
ça veut dire sortir des hébergements les
déboutés qui se maintiennent indûment ça
veut dire inciter au départ volontaire
avec un accompagnement dédié et 1500
places de départ vont être créés pour
cela et pour accompagner cette politique
ça veut dire aussi pour nous de mettre
en place une gestion régionale des
pièces il réduire la vacance dit
frictionnel alors à ces actions
s'ajoutent et moyens financiers
conséquents le point fort du plf 2021 en
matière d'hébergement pour nous c'est la
création de 6000 places supplémentaires
4 mai place au titre de la mission de
1000 places dans le cadre de la mission
relance
je vous détailler ces places si vous
voulez de l'ain il s'agit donc de place
de centres d'accueil des demandeurs
d'asile dont des cada pour 3000 places
des centres d'accueil et l'examen des
situations dks pour 1500 places et des
places de dispositif de préparation
retour les fameuses départ pour 1500
places pour le financement du parc et
les capacités totales en cadaquès et uda
c'est donc une dotation de 700 26,5
millions d'euros qui est prévu s'y
ajoutent 18,5 millions d'euros au titre
de la mission relance pour les 2000
places créées spécifiquement grâce au
plan de relance que j'évoquais
précédemment
j'ai mentionné l'amélioration des délais
de traitement de la demande d'asile
pour nous c'est une priorité forte qui
vient concrétiser l'engagement qui a été
votée dans la loi asile immigration et
l'engagement du christ dans la
république et pour nous c'est une
priorité
pourquoi d'abord parce que ça nous
permet d'accueillir dignement csg ce que
je veux vraiment le droit à la
protection en france
je pense notamment aux personnes qui
vivent dans des zones de guerre ou aux
personnes que nous accueillons parce
qu'il ya un engagement international
comme par exemple les yézidis coûte été
victimes d'un génocide commis par des ch
en irak et pour laquelle le président la
république s'est engagé à accueillir les
familles zidi avec leur enfant en france
et a contrario notre volonté c'est de
répondre rapidement à celles et ceux qui
n'ont pas vocation à rester sur le
territoire afin qu'on sorte de ces
situations qui ne sont positifs pour
personne dans lesquelles des personnes
viennent en france formule une demande
et attendent tellement longtemps contre
le moment là
des moments où on leur dit non mais en
fait elles sont restées dans une zone
grise en s'installant en france
et du coup il est de plus en plus
difficile pour les pouvoirs publics de
faire respecter les décisions quand les
décisions sont des décisions de négatif
donc nous pensons que arriver à réduire
les délais de réponse aux dossiers des
demandeurs d'asile aura uniquement un
effet favorable que des bonnes raisons
de 2,6 engagé donc c'est pour ça que
nous le faisons cette amélioration du
délai de la demande d'asile elle aura
aussi un impact sur le montant de la dda
mais également sur la fluidité de
l'hébergement je l'évoquais précédemment
et donc ça passe par un effort en termes
de moyens notamment en direction de
l'ofpra et donc là si la subvention qui
est accordée à l'ofpra au titre du plf
2021 de 92,8 millions d'euros elle
progresse de 1 03 % par rapport à 2000
ans et ce qu'il faut retenir à mon
humble avis c'est surtout que ça
signifie 200 e tp en plus j'ai fait un
point quel jour sommes mercredi
avant-hier avec le directeur général de
l'ofpra il m'a poussé renée que ces 200
personnes à temps plein avait bien déjà
été recrutés et était déjà depuis
plusieurs jours plusieurs semaines pour
plusieurs d'entre elles en poste à
l'ofpra venus renforcer les effectifs
qui gère justement le traitement de ces
dossiers nous voyons que on a là un
souhait d'augmentation qui nous
permettra de pérenniser ces dispositions
et de mieux traiter plus rapidement
traiter les dossiers des demandeurs
d'asile ensuite mieux lutter contre
l'immigration irrégulière
lors d'un déplacement récent avec le
ministre de l'intérieur le président la
république a annoncé dans la zone
frontalière du perthus dans les
pyrénées-orientales en doublement des
forces de sécurité qui sont déployés aux
frontières c'est déjà un effort
important et très concret
l'investissement immobilier des centres
de rétention administrative dekra que
vous trouverez dans le budget témoigne
là aussi je crois d'un engagement et la
volonté résolue du gouvernement trop
souvent on nous a dit que les mains le
manque de place en cra faisait obstacle
à l'éloignement donc ce sont 29 4
millions d'euros qui seront consacrés au
financement de la tranche 2021 du plan
d'extension des cra notamment je pense
aux opérations particulièrement d'olive
est et bordeaux ainsi que nouveau cra de
lyon qui va être livré fin 2021
d'après notre
projet de plan de charge nous avons par
ailleurs 6 millions de ses béquilles
sont prévus pour la création du cra de
nice et à tous ces montants s'ajoutent 1
4 million d'euros de cp au titre de la
mission relance pour la rénovation des
cra existants par ailleurs les préfets
ont été invités par le ministre de
l'intérieur c'est pas grave parce que
chacun se souviendra de comment je
m'appelle à part monsieur mélenchon mais
n'est pas parmi nous les préfets ont été
invités à créer des lra dans la tente de
la création de nouvelles places ou en
complément et donc ça j'aurais sachs a
eu ce notre volonté de pouvoir expulser
les étrangers radicaliser comme les miss
de l'intérieur elle a exprimé à de
nombreuses reprises ou ce qui représente
une menace manifeste pour l'ordre public
donc les frais d'éloignement des
étrangers en situation irrégulière tels
que budgétisé de la sorte il montre je
crois la volonté du gouvernement de
retrouver les niveaux d'éloignement qui
était comparable au niveau d'éloignement
précédant la crise sanitaire et ce poste
de dépense il couvre donc notamment les
frais dits de billetterie centrale mais
aussi le coût des aéronefs des
affrètements dédié à hauteur du montant
de 2020 c'est-à-dire de 24,5 millions
d'euros je voudrais maintenant vous dire
quelques mots sur l'intégration et
l'accès à la nationalité française
le programme 104 et je vais tenter
d'être rapide pour que nous ayons un pan
des changes si bien sûr je vous le
souhaitez
depuis plus de deux ans à la vente du
président la république le gouvernement
engagé une refonte de la politique
d'intégration en tant que tel et donc
l'état se donne les moyens de mener une
politique qui soit ambitieuse à travers
les mesures
est-ce que vous souhaitez que je
raccourcis ce monsieur le président non
ça va je remercie l'état se donne les
moyens mener cette politique ambitieuse
que j'évoquais à travers les mesures du
comité interministériel de l'intégration
du 5 juin 2018 et par un budget dédié
qui se maintient au niveau et qui
progresse même de 2 millions d'euros
pour 2021 donc c'est pour cela que j'ai
souhaité pouvoir accélérer la
naturalisation des travailleurs
étrangers qui ont été en première ligne
pendant la période de confinement
j'ai adressé avec le ministre de
l'intérieur une circulaire aux préfets
leur demandant de nous faire remonter
les dossiers de toutes ces personnes
aides soignants agents de sécurité
personnes qui ont gardé les enfants
personnel de ménage et cetera et cetera
qui se sont mobilisés
zep ans dans un confinement considérant
qu'ils ont fait montre de leur
attachement à la nation et contribuer à
l'effort national et nous avons demandé
donc que l'on puisse recensés dans les
départements l'ensemble des personnes
qui avaient déjà entamé une démarche de
demande de naturalisation et cette
démarche qui étaient en souffrance et
nous avons souhaité pouvoir l'accélérer
considérablement et donc je vous annonce
je ne crois pas avoir déjà donné ce
chiffre que nous avons reçues 1419
dossiers remontant de la part des
préfets pour des personnes qui ont
travaillé en première ligne pendant la
période de confinement et qui sont donc
à l'heure actuelle à l'étude
vis-à-vis des services pour que nous
vérifions si tous ces dossiers
correspond bien ou ne correspond pas aux
critères que nous avons définies telles
que travailleur de la première ligne
pendant le continent parmi les autres
actions prioritaires
très rapidement je voudrais vous citer
celle qui concerne la maîtrise de la
langue française et qui nous semble
fondamental à toutes et à tous je pense
ici
la formation civique pour le partage des
valeurs de la république et la
participation à la vie à la société
l'accès à l'emploi
la prise en charge de certaines
situations particulières comme celle des
réfugiés notamment de réfugiés de guerre
ou des femmes qui ont vécu des des
violences graves mais ces actions qui
sont portées par l'ofii sont aussi
portés par des porteurs de projets et
par des opérateurs ça me semble
important de vous le détailler
s'agissant de l'ofii ces crédits
d'intervention pour 2021 il s'élève un
montant qui est identique au montant de
2020 c'est à dire 11 millions d'euros
les actions d'intégration des
primo-arrivants elle elle augmente de 9%
ces crédits sont destinés à financer des
actions sur les territoires par exemple
l'accompagnement global vers l'emploi
comme certains opérateurs le porte
les crédits qui sont consacrés eux à
l'accompagnement des réfugiés il reste
prioritairement mobilisés pour le
financement des centres provisoires
d'hébergement de réfugiés les fameux cph
hauteur de 8700 10 places et donc ce
sont par exemple les familles et zigic
j'évoquais précédemment avec le présent
la république a souhaité pouvoir
accueillir en france après qu'elle ait
subi ce génocide de dèche en irak et
c'est crazy là ils sont complétés par
des actions d'accompagnement spécifique
qui progressent eux de 1,1
millions d'euros l'une des illustrations
les plus importantes
à mon humble avis de cet accompagnement
c'est le programme qui s'appelle up
hébergement orientation parcourir un
poids mais aussi beaucoup d'autres
initiatives sur le territoire qui mérite
d'être soutenu vous les connaissez je
voulais vous dire par ailleurs que le
ministère et pour en finir là le
ministère de l'intérieur accompagne
aussi la rénovation et la modernisation
des foyers travailleurs migrants et ça
c'est un engagement de longue date qui
court depuis 1997 dans le cadre de plans
pluriannuels qui se renouvelle pour
cette année ça concerne 690 foyers et
donc cent mille travailleurs immigrés
qui sont concernés par cet engagement
financier et pour accompagner ce
programme pluriannuel en 2021
le budget est maintenu à hauteur de 8,14
millions d'euros voilà j'en terminerai
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices
pour réaffirmer la volonté qui est la
nôtre avec le mythe de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin d'être juste dans notre
action en faveur de celles et ceux qui
rejoignent notre pays et de faire en
sorte que les actions que nous menons
soit comprise intelligible et nous le
souhaitons soit soutenue par le plus
grand nombre
je vous remercie merci madame la
ministre je vous propose pour des
raisons d'organisation ce que je crois
vous avez une obligation
après 17h30 de tout de suite donné la
parole à madame jourda et monsieur
bonnecarrère ainsi que monsieur me rends
s'ils le souhaitent pour rapporteur sur
le budget asile immigration et puis
ensuite
collecte qui souhaiteront de prendre la
parole pour vous interroger en redisant
à toutes et à tous avec beaucoup de
simplicité questions courtes de façon à
ce que nous puissions en avoir le plus
possible
merci même jourda merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre
une question qui fait écho à ce que vous
avez indiquée sur le fait que nous
partageons que les lois de la république
doivent être respectés et notamment que
l'éloignement doit être meilleur alors
il est en valeur absolue en 2019 je ne
prends pas les références 2015 bien
évidemment qui ne sont pas exploitables
il est en valeur absolue puisque le
nombre de décisions d'éloignement
exécuter plus important mais il ne l'est
pas en valeur relative puisque le nombre
de décisions d'éloignement et plus
important aussi ce qui fait qu'on tombe
à un taux relativement bas qui est de 12
2% et qui est en baisse par rapport aux
années précédentes
je voulais savoir quelles étaient vos
pistes de progrès pour améliorer
effectivement les décisions l'exécution
des décisions d'éloignement et je
voulais savoir si vous n'aviez pas
l'idée dans ce progrès de rendre
peut-être plus difficile l'accès au
territoire français et en amont
d'imposer des règles qui ne permettrait
pas de venir sur le territoire
peut-être aussi facilement allons nous
dire sachant que la dernière loi 2018
sur le thème de l'asile et des
migrations à faciliter le regroupement
familial et donc a rendu encore plus
possible cette entrée sur le territoire
ma deuxième question alors je l'adresse
également madame la ministre je rebondis
sur un propos de monsieur le ministre
qui avait indiqué qu'il ne fallait plus
pour certains ressortissants de certains
pays à accorder une protection de façon
quasi systématique comme c'était le cas
je ne cite pas exactement la phrase
monsieur nice mais je peut la retrouver
mais vous aviez parle effectivement de
production quasi systématiques alors
qu'elles sont c'est piqué ce qui permet
d'affirmer qu'il y à une protection
quasi systématique et quand on sait que
cette protection est accordée par
l'ofpra qui prend ses décisions de façon
indépendante
comment pensez vous pouvoir intervenir
précisément sur ces décisions et faire
qu'elle ne soit plus quasi systématique
et j'en ai fini
breathe in pti monsieur bonnecarrère
oui merci madame et monsieur le ministre
un constat et deux questions le constat
très rapide c'est que la bonne volonté
n'est pas récompensé dans le sujet de
laizy de l'immigration comme peut-être
dans d'autres sujets qu est ce que je
veux dire par là
comme vous l'avez très justement indiqué
vous avez majorer les crédits vis-à-vis
de l'eau fera le confinement a fait que
les officiers de protection n'ont pas pu
poursuivre les auditions les gens n'ont
pas pu se déplacer et l'objectif de
délai traitement à 60 jours qui avait
été prévu est maintenant repoussée au
mieux à 2023
vous avez augmenté les moyens de la cour
nationale de droit des îles permis de
conques ou deux concours de recrutement
de magistrats vacataires augmenter le
rapporteur et cetera et cetera
le confinement a fait que le cmdn n'a
pas pu être une n'a pas pu tenir ces
audiences
ceci à l'issue d'une grève des avocats
qui aboutissait exactement au même
résultat et sur la seconde partie du
volet que vous avez évoqué avec les
conditions d'hébergement vous augmenter
fortement les moyens budgétaires plus de
6000 places mais nous ne sommes jamais
qu'à 50% d'une demande qui depuis dix
ans ne cesse d'augmenter sur
l'éloignement ma collègue vient d'en
parler vous augmentez vous investissez
sur les serra et vous en prévoyez de
nouveau sauf qu'avec de kobe 19 la
moitié sont fermés pour la moitié qui
restent ils ne peuvent être utilisés que
pour la moitié de leur place vous
rajouter que pour expulser il faut que
vous puissiez avoir les accords
consulaires pouvoir justifier que les
personnes ne sont pas atteints du coc
u19 et bien entendu dans notre pays on
accepte qu'une personne ne se soumettent
pas à des tests
d'heuliez au côté de 19 de telle manière
qu'il est automatiquement et dq le sable
à partir de ce constat
votre tâche est indiscutablement très
délicate et pour reprendre une formule
qui n'est pas la mienne et mais qui est
celle de notre président le problème que
vous avez est traité n'est pas un
problème budgétaire il est aussi un
problème budgétaire mais c'est bien sûr
un problème qui est beaucoup plus
structurelle et donc je n'aurai que deux
questions la première pour vous demander
quel est le regard que vous portez sur
les projets de réforme du paquet asile
est ce que pour vous ce sujet d'abord de
traitement européen et si oui les
propositions faites vous satisfaite nous
a dit 16 ou non et deuxième question
plus franco françaises quelles sont vos
priorités
est-ce que vos priorités sont plutôt
centré par exemple sur la réforme du
contentieux des étrangers de
nationalités je pense aux vingt
propositions qu'ils ont été faites par
le conseil d'état est ce que vous êtes
sur des interventions plus ciblée madame
jourdain faisait face au nombre de
propositions est ce que vous êtes sur
une évaluation de la réforme portée par
monsieur collomb est exprimée encore
autrement monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur après les efforts
considérables que vous mobiliser sur le
texte sécurité après les ce qui va
suivre le livre blanc toujours sur la
sécurité
est ce que vous envisagez ou non
de nous présenter votre propre mouture
d'une réforme sur asile et migrations
merci de votre attention
si monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
meurent en août et de la commission des
finances
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues comme je viens de me dire
notre collègue la question est les
budgétaires via vous faites comme les
années précédentes
et avec ce que vous pouvez faire puisque
la question elle est d'ordre
géopolitique lorsque l'on à des conflits
en syrie en irak et ailleurs et que
budgétairement vous faites avec la loi
qui n'évolue pas dans le bon sens dans
la mesure où je vais changer de
paradigme complètement et le ccda est
plus épais que le code civil la
complexité tous les ans se rajoutent
et lorsque vous parlez de politique
migratoire maîtrise et équilibrée c'est
un souhait et c'est un souhait qui le
s'en rend bien compte les français
sentent bien content qu'ils aient vain
puisque lorsque onze fois il ya quelques
semaines à nice remontée quelqu'un de
tunisie d'italie et qui arrive à
vintimille à menton à nice et qui
produit cet acte odieux
on voit bien que nos frontières sont pas
maîtrisées et que c'est un drame lorsque
vous parlez de fermeté de l'état la
question d occulter force est une
galaxie des docteurs mais pas être 12%
il semblerait qu'on ait du mal à avoir
des chiffres dans mon département 802
occulter f 117 et exécuter une partie
fort c'est une partie un retour libre
donc cette question d occuper ça fait
des années que ça dure
et malheureusement avec ce budget n'y a
rien qui va changer et les moyens mis à
l'éloignement reste assez faible en
retour d'une trentaine de millions
d'euros depuis des années et
effectivement ce n'est pas forcément
qu'un problème budgétaire faut s'étonner
également de devoir des crédits de la
mission relance décret de la mission
relance ils sont faits sur 10
isolation de cra et là où je vous
reconnais budgétairement parlant des
efforts c'est les centres d'accueil des
centres d'accueil ce qui s'est passé à
saint ni montre s'est jamais suffisant
puisque évidemment on est dans une
posture où on remplit le tonneau des
danaïdes et dany de didier leschi par
l'hospitalité pour tous et en fait
l'hospitalité pour personne bien sûr
puisque du fait du différentiel de
niveau de vie entre notre pays
les services que nous offrons et bien
les autres pays subsahariens ou ailleurs
on n'a pas fini d'avoir une pression
migratoire c'est d'ailleurs une question
d'aujourd'hui d'une question de demain
et des années à venir donc la question
budgétaire elle est secondaire
effectivement je reviendrai quelles sont
vos priorités et moi je suis interpellé
sur la question de la sur les filières
de passeurs qu est-ce que vraiment vous
faites sur ces filières de passeurs car
là on se rend bien compte que il ya un
trafic d'êtres humains et n'y a aucune
générosité à faire mieux là dessus et
pour avoir été à la rencontre notamment
des plus jeunes et si la question du
nombre parce que lorsque cette question
de cette commission d'immigration
d'asile et d'intégration
évidemment l'intégration et l'asile se
fait forcément en fonction d'un nombre
et la différence de nombre sur les
enfants ou les jeunes accueillis est
reconnu comme mineur dit isolés dits non
accompagnés la question de la minorité
tawera une vrai débat ce que vous voulez
vraiment vous ans tous deux occupé cette
question ministre de la justice parle de
un peu plus de 16 mille mineurs lorsque
les départements parle de plus de 40
mille mineurs et lincou évidemment un
exemple un coup sur le département du
val d'oise moins de 4 millions d'euros
en 2011 44 millions en 2020 donc cette
question elle est fondamentale dans la
mesure où si ça touche la question de
sécurité
monsieur le ministre vous savez très
bien qu'il sert montrent que plus de la
moitié des cambriolages en région
parisienne sont le fait des dix mineurs
dits isolé donc la question des filières
de passeurs c'est une vraie question
question de l'accueil l'asile notamment
sur l'isi dit madame la une du site et
les ai dit je serai bien intéresser
combien de personnes de l'île
avons accueilli question aussi sur les
naturalisations de travailleurs
étrangers car la question des valeurs de
la république à questions notamment en
ce jour de droits des femmes la question
du comportement vis-à-vis de légalité
vis-à-vis des femmes qu'est ce que vous
avez en envisager pour tester un réel
partage de ces valeurs essentielles sur
les femmes comme sur autre chose bon et
je vais pas rallonger le propos mais je
voudrais dire que budgétairement parlant
évidemment du fait de la situation
on aurait pu penser que les dépenses
dada aurait été plus faible du fait de
l'allongement des crédits les des délais
d'instruction bien sûr ça n'a pas été le
cas et il faut quand même prendre
conscience que plus de la moitié des
d'appel administrative concernant le
droit des étrangers et et là ça pose de
problème tout simplement de notre droit
des étrangers
est ce que vous allez vous attaquer à la
réforme de ce droit des étrangers pour
réellement avoir une politique
migratoire maîtrise et équilibrée les
faire seuil de fermeté faire preuve de
fermeté également d'humanité pour ceux
qui méritent d'être français merci si
monsieur rang monsieur ou madame le
ministre la met la min ce pardon et puis
ensuite on donnera la parole à donner un
collègue qui ont déjà fait acte de
candidature
je vais répondre à certaines des
interpellations qui concerne à
proprement parler la mission asie
l'intégration ennemis de l'intérieur
s'ils le souhaitent bien sûr répondra
sur ce qui concerne plus généralement
les prérogatives qui sont les siennes
je vais commencer si vous permettez en
répondant par la faim d'abord sur ce que
nous souhaitons faire pour renforcer
l'adhésion aux valeurs de la république
moi je partage d'abord complètement
cette nécessité
bonjour on n'est pas là dont l'action du
budget à proprement parler mais la
politique commande le budget qui ensuite
nous en a vraiment je suis absolument
convaincu et c'est quelque chose que je
porte de longue date que l'adhésion aux
valeurs de la république doit absolument
être renforcées dans le parcours qui
amène à la nationalité parce que comme
l'a dit et prénom république devenir
français c'est une volonté mais c'est
aussi une volonté d'adhérer un ensemble
de valeurs et singulièrement aux valeurs
de la république et où nous avions
commencé à travailler sur un vade-mecum
a demandé aux administrations de
construire en vade mecum et de nous
elle forme de cérémonie d'accès à la
citoyenneté qui viendrait faire
déboucher ce parcours d'intégration dans
lequel nous avons déjà renforcé par
exemple le nombre d'heures de cours de
français mais dans lequel nous
renforçons aussi le nombre d'heures
d'apprentissage autour des questions de
valeurs de la république et d'égalité
entre les femmes et les âmes et moi je
n'ai absolument pas de problème
philosophique ou idéologique à dire que
c'est fondamental quand quelqu'un
devient français et acquiert la
nationalité française que de partager
sans aucune réserve ses valeurs sur
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
est donc c'est tout ce qui est piloté
également vous l'avez mentionné vous
même monsieur le sénateur par l'ofii et
c'est tout ce travail commun que nous
faisons ensemble avec ce vade-mecum qui
doit donner lieu à une refonte des
cérémonies de naturalisation profonde
que nous avons dû arrêter pour les
questions que chacun connaît de mesures
sanitaires
mais notre volonté c'est la poursuite de
ce qui a été fait au panthéon par le
président la république de donner un
caractère plus solennel aux cérémonies
de naturalisation afin d'engager aussi
autour des élus locaux qui participent
en général à ces cérémonies d'engager
également les familles les proches des
personnes qui acquièrent la citoyenneté
et de rappeler à cette occasion les
valeurs de la république de partager des
textes également de faire interpréter la
marseillaise et de donner un caractère
plus solennel à ce moment d'entrée dans
la citoyenneté sur la question des
yézidie je vais vous répondre sur le
fait que le prix honorifique s'était
engagé à accueillir 100 femmes
il est midi auprès de nadia mourad qui a
prix nobel de la paix au prix nobel de
la paix 2010 8 et qui est elle-même
survivante de ceux de ce génocide et
yézidie et nous avons dépassé cet
engagement du présent la république nous
sommes environ à 120 familles dit qu'ils
sont venus avec leurs enfants et donc au
total on est un petit peu plus de 500
personnes si je compte les enfants qui
sont venus avec les yézides vous
permettrait de vous dire que j'étais il
ya quelques semaines de cela en
déplacement dans le sud-ouest de la
france auprès d'un centre qui accueille
des familles avec leurs enfants et nous
avons eu la des personnes qui ont toutes
commencé leurs interventions part je
remercie la france et je crois que c'est
important de le dire parce que c'était
aussi le fort pour nous de faire un
déplacement et d'avoir des personnes qui
m'ont été réfugiés et qui sont en france
et qui commencent toutes par je remercie
france de m'accueillir et je remercie la
france d'instrument mes enfants en les
prenant à l'école voilà je voulais
partager avec vous parce que je pense
que c'est quelque chose aussi de très
positif sur la question des priorités en
ce qui me concerne les priorités du
serait que je mène sur la question de
l'asile auprès du ministre de
l'intérieur c'est bien sûr la réduction
des délais ça a été évoqué on sait je
crois toutes et tous à quel point c'est
en eux et à quel point effectivement
sueur sénateur vous avez raison les
moyens ne suffisent pas toujours
en tant que tel et c'est pour ça que
nous avons créé une task force sur ces
sujets que je réunis à mon ministère
toutes les semaines avec les directeurs
des différentes administrations mais
aussi des opérateurs afin de suivre
indicateurs par indicateurs la manière
dont on arrive à réduire ce temps de
délai mais on a effectivement je ne vous
le cache pas un délai qui est toujours
lourd notamment au niveau de la cnd à
nous nous observons dans nos indicateurs
qu'on est environ à sept mois de délai
traitement d'un dossier à la cnds
étaient environ cinq mois avant la crise
et je crois que c'est aussi important
parce que c'est une partie pas toute la
partie mais c'est une partie aussi du
délai de la réponse en ce qui concerne
l'offre a gelé mentionné ses 92 8
millions d'euros et donc 200 e tp en
plus qui sont déjà en poste et qui sont
déjà formés et déjà opérationnel l'ofpra
continue son travail malgré la période
de confinement il n'y a pas eu de
réduction dans ce deuxième confinement
le la réduction des transports n'a pas
entravé l'action les interprètes sont
toujours au travail les agents de
l'ofpra sont toujours au travail et donc
le directeur général de l'oprag me
disais il ya deux jours que le l'action
est toujours et toujours mené avec un
travail fin effectivement dans le
respect des prérogatives et d autonomie
ou indépendance des uns et des autres
mais également avec une exigence je me
permets de le dire forte de l'état ne
serait ce qu'en tant que financeur de
ces 200 de tp supplémentaires voilà pour
ce qui concerne la priorité sur l'asile
concernant la mission dont j'ai la
responsabilité
elle s'ajoute bien sûr à la question de
l'intégration parce que je crois que
l'intégration je le disais tout à
l'heure je n'ai pas de répéter mais elle
ne se résume pas à des chiffres où elle
est numéro de dossier mais aussi à la
manière dont on manifeste cette volonté
de devenir français cette volonté
d'adhérer à la république française donc
c'est à la fois le fait de renforcer les
parcours mais aussi la naturalisation à
des travailleurs qu'ovide que j'évoquais
précédemment
il semble que les autres questions
portaient sur notamment les sujets
d'éloignement et peut-être josé s'ils le
souhaitent la cmese de l'intérieur y
répondre senna ministre j'essaie de
répondre à l'ensemble de vos de vos
questions d'abord je partage l'idée que
ce n'est pas cliquer sur budgétaire
l'argent ne fait pas le bonheur mais
mais il contribue quand même un peu
l'efficacité surtout devant la masse de
difficultés qui sont devant nous et puis
la deuxième des choses je vous dit que
malgré les efforts ce n'est pas toujours
récompensée c'est vrai pas que dans la
politique migratoire ça peut être vrai
dans la vie en général mais n'est pas
nécessaire d'espérer pour entreprendre
ni même de réussir pour persévérer le
sénateur peut-être répond d'abord à la
question de savoir s'il faut une
nouvelle loi
moi je n'en suis pas du tout certain et
je pense que l'un des problèmes de notre
législation et peut-être même du
ministère de l'intérieur
c'est de rechercher dans la dans la
demande de nouvelles législations ce
qu'on est manifestement incapable soin
de résoudre au niveau international
puisque vous l'avez dit par définition
l'immigration est un sujet international
géopolitique et aussi par un souci de
l'efficacité de ce que déjà le parlement
a donné comme moyen omis de l'intérieur
d'intervenir je prends un exemple très
concret aujourd'hui les occulter fc un
an l'une des raisons pour lesquelles on
ne peut pas utiliser toujours c est qu
tfc qu'elles sont parfois pas prises à
bonne escient par l'autorité
préfectorale
je prends quelqu'un qui sera en prison
par exemple qui seraient étrangers en
situation irrégulière il se peut que en
même temps le juge
on ne peut rien dire mais enfin c'était
une bonne coordination avec la justice
et surtout l'autorité préfectorale prend
une décision administrative qui est le
cul tf
alors même que la peine de prison peut
être supérieure à une année donc il
passe toute l'année par exemple en
prison et puissantes entreprises ont
imaginé au bout d'un an et demi on se
dit pas légitimement va expulser cette
personne était de vitesse mais à des
sinistres hâtive de dures canon donc
c'est parce qu'on s'est mal coordonnés
et qu'on n'a pas plutôt vu avec
l'administration pénitentiaire comment
la veille ou l'avant-veille
c'est une évidemment une formule de
style cette personne va sortir de prison
qu'on devrait prendre cette décision
administrative pour pouvoir davantage
les moyens de pouvoir l'expulser
et ça j'ai pas besoin de vous demander
une cuite être prolongé de 2 ans de 3
ans de 82 5 ans il suffit simplement que
nous coordonnions mieux deuxièmement
l'autorité préfectorale n'ont pas
toujours la traduction de retour sur le
territoire national qui est une deuxième
décision administrative et il m'est
arrivé de constater que nous expulsions
parfois des étrangers mais qu'il
revenait assez vite dans des pays qui ne
sont pas très loin d'ici
notamment parce que nous avons pas trop
chez nous c'est le ministère de
l'intérieur
l'auto préfectorale n'a pas toujours
pris le deuxième document administratif
qui est l'interdiction de retour sur le
territoire national ça paraît
tautologique de dire que quand on a une
que tf on doit être interdit de retour
mais c'est pas évident c'est pas évident
parce que ce soit c'est la justice qui
se prononcer dans ces cas là il faut de
bonnes cordier ce que la justice soit
c'est une décision administrative est
l'une des réformes que nous allons faire
n a pas besoin de tes législatif j'ai
demandé avec les ministres directeurs
des étrangers en france de pouvoir faire
un seul document administratif ou encore
l'autorité préfectorale
je donne une vue tf1 dans le même
document on met en même temps une
interdiction de retour les deux sont
attaquables différemment par ailleurs
par l'étranger ci dessous est devant la
juridiction administrative
mais il n'ya pas d'oubli où il n'ya pas
de couplage vous voyez ça fait partie de
mon avis de soucis d'exécution qui me
paraît plus pragmatique et qui évite à
sa tombe de difficultés que nous pouvons
connaître et je n'ai pas besoin d'en
tourner vers le législateur pour
demander davantage de moyens c'est à
nous de mieux nous organiser
parmi les difficultés bon d'abord il ya
la meilleure tenue de nos frontières
commençons par le commencement pour
qu'il ya des gens qui pour éviter
d'expulser trop de personnes peut-être
qu'il faut éviter que trop de personnes
ne rentre donc c'est la tenue des
frontières d'abord lé schengen et c'est
pour la quatorzième fois puisque c'était
le cas du gouvernement de monsieur
hollande et c'est le cas ici
je renouvelle à la commission européenne
la demande d'une exception schengen dans
le cadre notamment des attentats
terroristes que nous connaissons mais
pas simplement et nous avons eu
l'autorisation de la commission
européenne pour effectivement doublé le
contrôle aux frontières il n'a jamais eu
autant de policiers de gendarmes aux
frontières métropolitaine
parce que vous l'avez vu présenter un
flic a annoncé ce doublement notamment
nous avons mis des essentielle des
moyens aujourd'hui qu'ils sont bien
manquant notamment côté espagnol qui est
une route de migration qui est désormais
de plus en plus importante dans par des
embarcations qui viennent directement
d'algérie qui arrivent sur les côtes
espagnoles
donc nous avons nous essayons de tenir
nos frontières nous essayons parce que
chacun sait qu évidemment cela est très
difficile
ensuite nous essayons de faire de la
coopération avec nos pays voisins
jusqu'à présent on était peut-être un
petit peu trop en chiens de faïence
appliquant ainsi les doubles ine je te
dis reprend je les reprends pas c'est
assez compliqué j'ai été voir ma
collègue italienne
nous sommes mis d'accord sur ce que la
france demande depuis très longtemps et
je l'en remercie puisque nous allons
inaugurer cela au mois de décembre
des patrouilles franco italiennes elles
sont formées à partir du 1er décembre en
commun à partir du 10 décembre
elles seront entre vintimille et menton
elles vont permettre de permettre
d'éviter ce sorte de marché de dupes qui
est parfois dublin avec des gens que
l'on remet qui repasse que l'on remet
qui repasse et qui épuise les forces de
l'ordre bien évidemment et qui finit
effectivement par être efficace pour ce
qui se joue les passeurs et pas
simplement des différences et donc la
coopération transfrontalière est une
bonne chose
je rencontrerai mon homologue qui vient
d'être nommé du gouvernement belge
puisque 60% des gens qui sont à calais
viennent de belgique
faut pas croire que ce sont des monter
directement de menton au pas de calais
la route principale est celle qui
malheureusement vient de belgique ou des
pays-bas pour arriver à calais puis ce
conseil depuis bonaparte
c'est l'endroit sans doute le plus
rapide avec boulogne-sur-mer pour aller
directement en angleterre donc nous
devons tenir nos frontières par des
hommes mais aussi par la coopération
transfrontalière
la troisième des choses que je voudrais
évoquer c'est évidemment la question
géopolitique et tamara question des
visas président de la république il a
pris une décision très forte l'année
dernière sur la réduction des visas
notamment envers l'algérie
nous avons une discussion c'est vrai
pendant ce temps aujourd'hui elle
convient donc que les choses sont un peu
compliquées pour 2020 mais dans la
tournée
notamment des pays du maghreb que j'ai
fait du président de la république j'ai
très clairement dit au pays
évidemment lutte antiterroriste est
extrêmement forte mais aussi la
politique migratoire que si les
étudiants
si la coopération économique était
évidemment repas du tout dans l'optique
gouvernement de les limiter je pense que
c'est important que nous puissions
garder c'est cette immigration là nous
devons couple et notre politique de
visas avec la politique des laissez
passer consulaires et que si nous ne
faisons pas alors c'est un marché de
dupes et le président de la république
l'a très clairement évoqué aux
dirigeants qui l'a eu au téléphone avant
ma visite c'était évidemment le cas pour
les gens qui étaient hors effet ce
pertes et ça c'est de même pas
négociable c'est une vérité première
et puis c'est sur la politique
migratoire en général je pense que le
président arrivé quand leurs occasions
de s'exprimer dans quelques temps avant
d'aller très rapprochées sur cette
question notamment prévision du débat
parlementaire sur l'immigration que nous
avons chaque année la troisième des
choses c'est une question qui relève de
la politique d'asile ou ce que monsieur
le sénateur bancaire vous avez appelé le
paquet asile
effectivement la commission européenne a
fait une proposition qui nous paraît
satisfaisante sur l'immigration et
l'asile
nous avons plusieurs conseil européen
nous en aurons à jesper conclusif au
mois de décembre pour adopter ce paquet
asile mais la france n'adoptera pas
n'importe quoi et de retrait aligné avec
le gouvernement allemand qui aujourd'hui
président vous savez l'union européenne
pour que ce pack asie il repose sur deux
jambes et ses deux jambes doivent être
musclé de la même façon la première
c'est une jambe qui doit notamment
permettre que les demandeurs d'asile
dont nous devons étudier
évidemment toutes les demandes et dans
un cadre européen sinon il ya
effectivement des difficultés
je rappelle que si l'italie connaît
l'essentiel de l'immigration d'asile
c'est bien en france qu est le plus de
monde à 10,2 par rapport à l'italie
vingt mille en italie 60000 quand ça
vient de la route méditerranéenne donc
il ya beaucoup de gens qui vivent en
italie
mais l'essentiel viennent en france pour
des raisons assez compréhensible soit
parce que il essaye d'aller en
angleterre et non qu'ils fassent par la
france soit parce qu'ils ont une
communion de travail d'esprit de famille
de langue avec le territoire national
surtout lorsqu'ils viennent des pays
francophones comme sont les béni mered
goût de certains
pays d'afrique sub sahariens donc nous
disons nous que nous devons accepter les
demandes d'asile et les étudier que dans
les pays d'arrivée et donc nous
souhaitons qu'il y ait en arrivé en
italie en arrive en espagne en arriver à
malte en arrivant en grèce ces gens
arrivent en france n'arrive en france
mais ne sommes pas le premier pays qui
est qui est au rendez-vous de cette
route d'avoir des endroits où les
demandeurs d'asile restent et en
quelques semaines nous étudions la
demande d'asile est ce demandeur d'asile
peu de très bien demander l'asile en
france
nous pouvons très bien financer une
partie de ces centres d'asile de pour
imaginer même détachée les agents
publics pour aller étudier cet asile
dans ces pays mais nous devons les
retenir
là où ils sont arrivés en premier sur le
territoire européen
c'est tout à fait important c'est tout à
fait révolutionnaire au sens asie du
terme
ça gêne évidemment les pays de transit
est rentré d'italie l'espagne malte et
la grèce est la contrepartie c'est la
deuxième jambe c'est que nous devons
solidarité à ces pays et la france est
très bien placé pour le dire puisque à
chaque fois nous avons joué cette
solidarité
à chaque fois nous avons accepté de
prendre notre part contrairement à bien
d'autres pays notamment un syndrome de
pays qui peuvent donner la leçon ici ou
là nous avons accepté d'être solidaire
des maltais des italiens des espagnols
et nous lisons autant plus que si nous
ne faisons pas ce sont les turcs qui
protégeront ces pays et ses frontières
comme ils le font déjà à malte et qui
peuvent le faire demain pour d'autres
pays pour des raisons géopolitiques que
nous connaissons est donc tout disons
que les deux jambes du paquet
migratoires c'est à la fois des entrées
avec gens qui restent dans le territoire
où ils sont entrés dont on devons nous
devons rapidement
regardez l'asile si les gens sont
acceptés des pays qui ont eu la demande
d'asile doit les accepter bien une seule
demande dans tous les pays européens pas
plusieurs demandes dans plusieurs pays
européens ce qui est aujourd'hui le cas
et d'autre part effectivement la
solidarité que nous devons à ces pays du
sud si j'ose dire pour faire vite
notamment dans la répartition du nombre
de personnes qui arriverait sur le
territoire européen
nombre de personnes qui pourraient
augmenter au lendemain de la crise
sanitaire résolu si nous
nous avons un peu d'optimisme il ya
aussi des conséquences afin de la crise
crise sanitaire le de la chose que je
vais vous qu'avez-vous puisque ça a été
fait par le 2 septembre
vous avez évoqué me semble-t-il ou
madame passat riespach dont la priorité
aux qu'est ce que nous faisons en
premier notre héritage politique
migratoire en avoir la priorité des
priorités notamment danse autant de co
vide c'est de pouvoir expulser du
territoire national
toutes les personnes qui sont fichés
islamistes radicaux qui sont étrangers
en situation irrégulière qu'ovide ou
paco vide
cela fonctionne nous ce j'avais évoqué
le chiffre de 2 131 avant les attentats
d'ailleurs étrange aussi sur régulière
fichiers oev espère t il y en a plus
d'une centaine 51 sont actuellement au
cra où je vous parle
57 autres expulsés depuis ma conférence
de presse 29 sont assignés à résidence
donc plus de la moitié sont hors d'état
de nuire ou sont expulsés du territoire
national
ces fichiers ofs perte est évidemment
doivent pouvoir continuer et parmi les
difficultés que nous avons c'est
évidemment d'avoir une discussion avec
les pays dont nous n'avons pas de
relations diplomatiques et syriens la
libye tout ça et est bien compliqué bien
sûr mais c'est une part infime de
personnes que nous ne pouvons pas
expulser puisque les bocaux gens
l'avaient d'une tenant des relations les
pays du maghreb la russie j'ai déjà
évoqué des pays d'afrique des pays
d'asie et nous nous sommes nous sommes
actuellement en train de le faire on a
réussi à deux jours notamment à excuser
ce n'avait jamais été fait dans ces
conditions trois afghans qui étaient
respectés dont il était très difficile
de faire éloignement et malgré le vide
et malgré l'éloignement et la difficulté
du pays avec le gouvernement afghan
nous avons réussi à trouver un travail
de laisser passer consulaire ça c'est la
priorité des priorités c'est que j'ai
donné des instructions très claires au
préfet et à jeudi au sénateur d'oran je
n'ai pas besoin d'une d'un nouveau texte
est négatif pour ça pour appliquer les
lois de la république et quelles sont
elles
tout étranger y compris qu'à une carte
de résident qui troublent gravement
l'ordre public c'est à dire qui est
coupable de faits de délinquance
extrêmement fort pas des voleurs de
pommes des gens qui commettent des actes
extrêmement forts doivent se voir
retirer leur carte de résident et
expulsés du territoire national
si je prends l'exemple de la seine saint
denis depuis cette instruction du 29
septembre que je tiens à votre
disposition sont 1200 renouvellement de
carte de résident 130 ont été retirés ou
pas renouveler et donc j'ai demandé à
tous les préfets je ferai un pour la
semaine prochaine avec des ministres
l'application de cette circulaire doit
être précise
et moi je le dis devant la commission
des lois bien sûr qu'être étrangers en
situation régulière sur le territoire
national ce n'est pas bien mais entre
deux personnes que nous devons expulser
dans les conditions que vous avez
évoquée parfois compliqué je préfère que
nous nous concentrions sur ceux qui ne
respectent en aucun cas les lois de la
république et qui en plus d'être
étranger sur l'aiguillé recommettre des
actes qui troublent l'ordre public et
cela effectivement doivent être la
priorité des expulsions des mises en cra
et des expulsions
troisième chose que je voulais évoquer
sur ce point c'est la question de
l'asile vous avez évoqué sa madame la
sénatrice de mémoire 20 % des demandes
d'asile sont faits de personnes venant
de pays sûr on a du mal à comprendre
comment on peut être d'un pays sur et
demander l'asile
alors le comprend aisément puisque il
peut y avoir des raisons pour lesquelles
dans ces pays sûrs au monde l'asile
l'orientation sexuelle par exemple en
fait partie on peut avoir un pays sûr
reconnu comme tel et pour autant une
pratique que la france condamne ou que
la france permet de recevoir ces
personnes qui sont persécutés en raison
de l'orientation sexuelle je lui dis
mérite évidemment d'être d'être regardé
il ne faut pas dire qu'on ne regarde
aucun dossier de pays sûrs mais
cependant pourrait quand même considérer
que ces 20% là peuvent être vues plus
rapidement parce que nous savons que son
pays sur et dans des cas plus simple
sans doute que lorsque ils viennent d'un
pays qui n'est pas considérée comme sûre
je prends un deuxième exemple madame la
sénatrice
il ya aujourd'hui des rendez vous
individuels pour chaque personne ne
serait ce que pour l'explication des
droits et je voudrais pas toujours les
traducteurs pour les personnes donc fait
venir un traducteur et à chaque fois
quand ya pas de traducteur bas vous ne
pouvez pas donner des droits
nous avons travaillé pas la ministre
pour que au moins la présentation des
droits puisse se faire de manière ou
moins collective et faire venir un
traducteur à des rendez-vous collective
en petit groupe ce qui nous fait gagner
du temps
la cndh on n'est pas là que le vice
président du conseil d'état l'un des
problèmes c'est qu'à trois juges et que
en période de vide
naturellement mais pas que quand vous
avez trois juges c'est parfois plus
compliqué que quand vous avez un juge
unique raison que seul sénateur 50% du
contentieux du droit public dans les
tribunes administratif ses droits des
étrangers
c'est un peu moins vrai pour le conseil
d'état mais c'est 50% pour être
illustratif et les juges eux-mêmes sont
très frustrés de voir faire que du droit
des étrangers
et deuxièmement ne pas voir
l'application des décisions parce que
souvent les eaux du tf sont appliquées
c'est ce que vous avez évoquées donc
nous avons proposé au conseil en conseil
d'état de travail et que c'est bien pour
voir ça peut pas faire un jeu ludique
dans certaines formations comme on peut
améliorer les procédures et imaginer un
certain nombre de rapidité
administrative donc pour résumer
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
c'est vrai que les chiffres par rapport
aux demandes certains augmentent elles
ne sont pas satisfaisantes
je voudrais quand même dire que ce sont
135 mille demandes d'asile pour que les
français qui nous écoutent le sache
il y en a plus de 5000 qui sont refusés
chaque année la france n'est pas un pays
laxiste nous naturalisant 25000
personnes de moins que sous le
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy par
exemple qui était pas déjà me
semble-t-il un quinquennat très très
très très très laxiste également mais il
est vrai période de kobe de mise à part
que nous devons améliorer le processus
administratif pour mieux coordonnée avec
l'autorité judiciaire est plus concret
dans nos décisions
même si la solution est évidemment
européenne merci monsieur ministre je
profite du micro pour deux observations
ou de questions la première c'est
aurions besoin de fassiez le point sur
la lutte contre les filières
d'immigration les filières clandestines
leurs démembrements
la deuxième question qui peut se poser
c'est quelles sont les relations
actuelles entre dans l'accord europe
turquie plutôt turquie grèce sur la
maîtrise de la frontière au large de
lesbos et puis la dernière question ou
plutôt une observation
en tous les cas titre personnel je suis
ravi que vous puissiez
conditionner l'obtention de laisser
passer consulaire à la délivrance de
visas
je crois que nous n'éviterons jamais
cette possibilité bien au contraire
le seul moyen d'établir un rapport de
force suffisant qui va être d'obtenir
ces laissez-passer consulaires
absolument nécessaire pour les
reconduites à la frontière de l'avion
proposé au sénat dans un texte
ça n'avait pas été retenu à l'époque il
est écouté
tant mieux si cela fonctionne et si ça
peut se mettre en place indépendamment
d'autres sujets j'ai plusieurs questions
posées par des collègues
madame la ministre devait nous quitter
mais je l'avais dit avant donc pas de
souci d'abord monsieur le comte puy
monsieur thani mohamed soilihi
puis madame l'herbe y est puis ensuite
monsieur philippe bas et madame nathalie
goulet
monsieur le comte vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président de ses
ministres je vais vous poser quelques
questions sur ambac tuer la mise en
place d'une part de du dispositif ethias
au niveau européen et des moyens que que
sa demande dans chaque pays membre
est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire un
point sur le sujet sur les moyens et ce
qu'ils sont dans le budget pour la mise
en oeuvre de ce projet d'autorisation
d'entrer sur le territoire pour les
ressortissants des pays non soumis aux
obligations de visas
deuxième question on peut constater
souvent que lorsqu'une personne est
constaté en situation irrégulière elle
ne passe pas devant une borne eurodac en
france parce qu'on en a pas assez
est-ce que vous avez un plan
d'équipement de borne eurodac est de
systématiquement faire passer les
personnes constatées en situation
irrégulière dans une borne eurodac
concernant les préfectures on a une
grosse difficulté cette année avec la
difficile
les difficultés d'accès en par tuer pour
les demandes de passeport est-ce que
vous avez un plan en particulier pour
pouvoir faire des demandes de passeports
en ligne en particulier avec le
dispositif à 10 m qui est en voie de
finalisation
concernant les l'accès aux préfectures
la demande d'asile
c'est quasiment impossible d'arriver
dans des délais corrects à faire une
demande d'asile en préfecture
je dois constater aussi que aujourd'hui
pour faire une demande de naturalisation
s'est parfois trois ans avant d'opter
une nouvelle sur des dépôts de dossiers
et on doit constater aussi que des
personnes qui ne peuvent pas rentrer
chez elle parce que elles ne peuvent pas
compte tenu de la pandémie n'arrive pas
à avoir accès aux préfectures pour des
prolongements de leurs visas de court
séjour
comment faire dans des situations comme
celle ci est ce que vous avez un plan
pour effectivement qu'ils aient un accès
réel aux préfectures lorsque l'on a
besoin ou est ce que l'on doit se
résoudre
comme dans le cas de deux que j'évoquais
tout de suite à des situations de
personnes qui vont être en situation
irrégulière parce que les préfectures ne
sont pas capables de répondre aux
besoins
merci monsieur le comte monsieur thani
mohamed soly
merci monsieur le président mais c'est
le ministre dans les documents annexés
il est fait un lien entre la politique
d'hébergement des demandeurs d'asile et
la lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière sur ce point 1500 places
sont annoncés pour 2021 au sein du
dispositif de préparation et des de
retour dpr afin de favoriser les retours
volontaires
dans le même temps la poursuite de
l'augmentation du nombre de places dans
les centres de rétention administrative
est prévue afin de renforcer
l'effectivité des recours forcé les deux
questions comment les territoires
d'outre-mer et notamment mayotte dont
chacun connaît la problématique
migrateurs spécifiques et qui n'est pas
nouvelle sincères t-il dans la stratégie
de la mission pour l'année 2020 en
composés pour deux tiers des crédits
alloués à la garantie de l'exercice du
droit d'asile et seconde question
comment les nouvelles places de dpr et
de crds à se décliner vont-ils dans les
territoires ultramarins
je vous remercie merci madame la vie oui
monsieur le ministre vous avez évoqué en
partie la question que qui m'intéressait
concernant justement les étrangers en
situation irrégulière en prison
il ya deux ans de ça on était allé avec
la commission des lois
quelques-uns notamment notre président
monsieur lui fait et de trois autres
pour visiter le camp de le centre de
rétention de lesquin et l'on s'était on
s'était on a été complètement surpris de
voir que beaucoup d'entre eux avaient
séjourné en prison pendant quelques fois
de long séjour et que rien n'avait été
envisagée pendant ce séjour en prison
on parle de délai à raccourcir la de
toute évidence on avait sous la main des
personnes qui pouvaient être dont le
dossier pouvait être organisé pour un
retour parce qu'on avait de toute
évidence
des gens qui devaient retourner suite à
une condamnation
c'est vrai qu'avec les tribunes
administratif il ya beaucoup de deux de
tension on va dire quelques fois parce
que rien de voir le nombre d'avocats qui
se spécialise en endroit
des étrangers on s'aperçoit qu'il ya
forcément des contentieux très long
alors ma question porte justement sur
ces délais est-ce que vous avez des
points précis pour réduire les temps
d'exposition justement on avait remarqué
aussi une chose c'est que dans ces camps
de rétention et notamment celui de
lesquin il y avait beaucoup de violence
et on sent été surpris parce que c'est
un conte qui doit être normalement tout
à fait calme il n'y a pas de raison
d'avoir cette violence on sentait
vraiment qu'il y avait une tension très
très forte
on a trouvé que c'était quelque part un
peu inadmissible si cher collègue
monsieur philippe bas merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre vous tout
de même bien reconnaître que il y a une
attractivité relative de la france
vis-à-vis de l'immigration qui fait que
pour les migrants notre législation mais
aussi notre système administratif
présente l'un des avantages comparatifs
les plus grands parmi les pays européens
est plus facile d'entrer dans notre pays
que d'en être expulsé vous en est bien
conscient vous avez vous même rappelé
les chiffres vous avez si j'ai bien
interpréter votre propos exprimé des
réticences à l'idée de faire évoluer la
législation
et à défaut de rechercher une grande
réforme de l'immigration il ya peut-être
quand même un certain nombre de points
qu'il faut traiter certains d'ailleurs
ne relève pas de la loire aujourd'hui on
n'a pas le droit de faire
systématiquement des tests osseux pour
vérifier la jda mineurs isolés étrangers
est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas modifié sa
aujourd'hui la cour de cassation
quand il ya un état civil manifestement
faux dit qu'il faut le respecter
est ce qu'on ne peut pas modifier sa
aujourd'hui le regroupement familial
comporte des conditions de logement qui
sont quand même d'une attractivité peu
commune un tout petit logement permet
d'accueillir de nombreux enfants on ne
peut pas changer ça aujourd'hui on
continue si j'ai bien compris à
appliquer la circulaire
valls sur les régularisations
entendez-vous très fortement montrer à
la face du monde que la france va cesser
de régulariser de manière libérale
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas imposer le
test dépistage du coc vide à des
étrangers en centres de rétention et
certains pays d'origine s'en servent de
prétexte pour ne pas reprendre leurs
nationaux est ce qu'on ne peut pas
changer ça aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
procédure accélérée de rejet des
demandes manifestement infondée à
l'ofpra ou à la cour nationale du droit
d'asile est ce qu'on ne peut pas créer
des procédures plus rapides quand
vraiment on est en présence se manifeste
d'une demande frauduleuse
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas prolonger la
rétention de d'étrangers radicaliser
tant que l'achèvement des formalités n'a
pas eu lieu et on est obligé de les
libérer au bout d'un certain délai
est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas prévoir une
procédure spécifique pour les garder
plus longtemps en centre de rétention
vous voyez quand on regarde les choses
précisément et qu'on ne se pose pas la
question de savoir s'il faut une grande
loi
immigration pas il ya quand même pas mal
de choses qui méritent réflexion et
action rapide ne vous paraît-il pas que
la loi relative aux valeurs de la
république je ne sais plus comment il
faut l'appeler mais elle va rapidement
être discutées pour être un bon support
pour introduire toutes ces mesures et
êtes vous prêts à soutenir les
initiatives parlementaires en ce sens
merci alors madame nathalie goulet qui
est en visioconférence je pense qu'elle
nous entends je vous en suis une reprend
tout à fait celle de ne finit pas vous
savez que j'ai à une attention
particulière sur la fraude documentaire
sur elle nous avons identifié à 7,1
nombre de procédures et un certain
nombre d'améliorations pour les
questions de contrôle des documents
notamment avec la paf est ce que vous
pensez qu'on va pouvoir améliorer ces
dispositifs est donnée à la part plus de
moyens l'autre sujet est une une
évaluation de l'application de l'article
729 2 du code de procédure pénale qui
permet donc des libérations
conditionnelles à condition que la
personne libérée quittent le territoire
ça permettrait éventuellement à la fois
de libérer des places de détention et
surtout de faire quitter le territoire
des gens qui sont indésirables sur le
territoire français est ce que vous avez
une évaluation de l'application de ce
texte qui existe dans le code de
procédure je remercie mes amis je vais
vous donner la parole peut-être à
l'issue des réponses coffret vous
pourriez présenter la partie sécurité
civile 2
budget est ainsi je vous aurais la
parole ensuite madame dumont madame
clerval et monsieur dominati tu me dis
je vais à parle donc vous souhaitez
monsieur le président que je réponde aux
questions et que je présente ensuite
sécurité d'accor bien alors j'essaie de
réponse sur les monsieur lui j'essaye de
tenir leur loge
non je suis à votre d'intérêt du débat
est essentiel il ya beaucoup de
questions à vous poser
je joue temps j'avoue que je me retiens
aussi mais j'essaye de tenir les délais
va mais je suis à votre disposition pour
venir ce soir demain ou après demain si
vous le souhaitez bon j'ai un très bon
rapidement mais vincent j'espère
exhaustive aux questions posées d'abord
peut-être par vous même monsieur le
président vous avez évoqué la question
des filières et la question d'autres
relations de la turquie et l'union
européenne avec la turquie sur la
question de la relation entre l'union
européenne et la turquie
il ya un conseil d'européens 11 décembre
prochain qui fera à la fois son
évaluation etc en tirer les conséquences
au niveau
pardon quand on n'est pas au niveau
européen au niveau européen
je peux dire qu'en tant que ministre et
parieurs sur les relations que nous
avons avec l'état à l'état turc quelque
chose se passe correctement temps soit
lutte antiterroriste protocole cazeneuve
que sur notre travail autour de
l'immigration mais c'est une position
évidemment repeignent que nous devons
prendre et je crois que le conseil du 11
décembre sera un moment important
d'abord ministériel puis entre les chefs
d'état soit les filières les
démantèlements s'accélère même pendant
les périodes de confinement jeu quelques
chiffres qui pourraient vous intéresser
on est passé de 103 fille a démantelé en
2013 pour passer à peu près à 286 en
2016 et on est à 328 en 2019 et nous
sommes à 126 depuis
entre le 1er janvier et le 30 juin
malgré le confinement alors quand les
chiffres augmentent on sait pas très
bien si c'est des services y sont plus
efficaces aussi c'est le look de
froideur qui augmente on connaît ça dans
tous les chiffres qui concernent ses
activités en tout cas je peux vous dire
que les choses sont ne sont pas
délaissés
d'ailleurs nous avons fait mettre dans
le pacte migratoire européen un chapitre
spécifique sa lutte contre les passeurs
et les filières évidemment de passeurs
qui se nourrissent et se réjouissent de
la misère humaine et en angleterre j'ai
installé trois semaines après mon
arrivée c'était une demande importante
les présents de la république avec ma
collègue madame pretty une filière
franco anglaise faut lutter contre les
passeurs dans la mer du nord et sont
très nombreux ils sont installés d'un à
coquelles et il travaille et leur
efficacité est grande même si évidemment
nous devons toujours continuer je
jouerai bien de le dire que ces passeurs
et viennent parfois de très loin
quand nous avons des bagues l'inde et
qui arrive au maghreb et singulièrement
tunisie ou en algérie et qui se
retrouvent ensuite passant par l'italie
en france le détour pour le bangladesh
la france en passant par le maghreb
montre que les passeurs sont à la fois
imaginatif et exploite énormément la
misère humaine et il faut voir dans
quelle situation
pour le coup les auditions de la police
pour cette instance d'être un leurre ce
sens hier montre à quel point leur route
a été un calvaire et je n'en dirai pas
plus pour pas gâcher davantage la soirée
mais c'est des choses extrêmement
évidemment poignante et touchante et qui
démontre que c'est évidemment des
activités de passeurs que nous devons en
premier lieu condamné j'ai par ailleurs
demandé la dg des sites aussi intéresser
tout particulièrement sur de nombreuses
questions ont été posées j'essayais
répond très rapidement d'abord au sein
tant le contenu sur ethias donc première
première premier test d'interconnexion
sans doute à la mi année prochaine puis
décembre 2022 pour son arrivée
généralisée et sur eurodac j'ai un peu
du mal je fais c'est de répondre en même
temps monsieur bas sur cette question à
comprendre votre question sur les
bordereaux d'elle parce qu'en fait dans
la loi française il n'est pas possible
d'obliger de prendre des empreintes et
donc on peut multiplier des bornes
mais si on peut pas obliger les gens à
prendre des empreintes c'est un peu
compliqué voilà peut-être une réforme
législative qui mériterait d'être vu par
le parlement et notamment pour permettre
au département là je renvoie sur la
question des mineurs isolés le fait de
pouvoir les rentrées dans les fichiers à
m
il ya aujourd'hui un tiers des
départements de france notamment et
départements où il ya le plus de mineurs
isolés sont parfois les départements qui
demande aussi le plus d'argent à l'état
tom de compensation protection de
l'enfance français car évidemment de
certains départements franciliens
commencer par le premier qui n'ont pas
de fichier voilà donc que c'est un des
sujets je sais que le premier ministre
est une aujourd'hui une négociation
assez assez ferme
mais la prise d'empreintes n'est pas
obligatoire aujourd'hui un policier ne
peut pas obliger quelqu'un à prendre ses
empreintes et deuxièmement on peut pas
donc l'entrée d'un fichier à m
pourtant leur date ne serait bien utile
donc l'idée quand même du pacte
migratoire de dire à l'entrée de
l'europe
on prend les empreintes de tout le monde
et on fait une demande d'asile permet de
savoir ce fichier eurodac qui
permettrait de lutter fortement contre
les mineurs isolés je crois plus à
monsieur le sénateur cas la question des
on est est moindre dans quelques
instants sur le
l'évocation du monsieur le sénateur élu
à mayotte 4,227 place imaginez pour les
territoires ultramarins je n'ai pas le
nombre de grappes pour votre
département monsieur le seul sénateur
mais je vais me rendre bientôt le
sénateur le corps nu on aura l'occasion
d'en parler
effectivement nous avons augmenté sans
cesse depuis trois ans j'en ai été
témoin quand j'étais ministre des
comptes publics à la fois l'hébergement
d'urgence et l'hébergement tout court
qu'il s'agisse évidemment des personnes
qui sont en difficultés sociales comme
des personnes qui sont étrangères en
attendant de la voir la raison de
l'administration ou la justice
administrative parfois les deux se
confondent dans une difficulté
budgétaire et pratiques que nous avons
et je crois que c'est cette augmentation
existe encore je pense qu'un embargo pu
défendre ce budget devant peut-être
votre commission ou devant le sénat ça
n'est jamais assez mais c'est un montant
extrêmement important et d'ailleurs le
travail que fait préfet d'île de france
je remercie beaucoup et les préfets de
région cdc de répartir au mieux les
personnes et c'est sûr que la facilité
de sorel et ses décors s'installer comme
c'est le cas d'autres de l'autoroute à
que j'ai fait démantelé dans des
conditions d'insalubrité extrêmement
extrêmement forte il faut bien voir
comment les choses se sont passées et
parfois il ya un certain nombre on va
dire de d'actions qui ne servent pas les
migrants eux mêmes c'est le mot con
qu'on puisse dire on aura peut être
l'occasion d'en reparler
madame verbier jeu pour savoir partie
répondu à sa question mais la question
des trois tiers d'étrangers en situation
irrégulière en prison elle et elle est
pareil que la question des étrangers en
situation régulière en prison et d'eau
pour le coup on devrait voir
effectivement qu'on puisse le retirer
leurs cartes de résidence il dort faits
sont extrêmement importants ça demande
aussi une bonne coopération entre le
ministère de la justice ces migrations
pénitentiaire et et la police et cette
difficulté c'est une meilleure
information en effet entre les préfets
et les directeurs de prisons pour que
lorsque les gens vont sortir on puisse
mieux les accompagner et qu'ils passent
moins de temps possible en cra parce que
ce n'est pas facile pour personne
évidemment
à commencer par la personne qui est dans
un cas pour être effectivement expulsés
du territoire national et donc un
travail aussi diplomatique pour avoir ce
laisser-passer consulaire
la difficulté vient du moment où le camp
le juge d'application des peines libère
à la personne avant le terme normal
compris avec remise de peine et parfois
les préfets me témoignent que ben oui
même avec la remise de peine est bien
calculé puis il arrive que quelques
jours avant cette personne est libéré ça
c'est une des difficultés et sans
remettre en cause le jugement du juge
d'application des peines il faudrait au
moins qu on prévoir soit à délais ce
moment une décision en amont qui
permettent à l'autorité administrative
de mieux s'organiser l'encore france
quoique ce soit législatif
c'est une meilleure organisation que
nous devons avoir c'est un des défauts
de notre système et on doit pouvoir
encourager ce que même laisser des gens
pendant plusieurs mois en prison
assignation à un crouch nation résidence
c'est pas une bonne chose pour ces
personnes aiment et parfois peut pousser
à des actes de violence comme vous
l'avez évoqué alors monsieur le cintrage
je peux partager un certain nombre de
vos de vos propos le cas de l'état civil
manifestement défaillant en est un
l'attractivité relative de la france je
la partage en partie c'est pas tout à
fait vrai notamment depuis la réforme de
l'armée
c'est en parti vrai il faudrait
effectivement pour se comparer y a pas
que ça qui joue il ya aussi le fait qu'
il ya une communauté de destin qui fait
que quand vous parlez français bavouzet
tendance à aller là où les gens parlent
français
et puis quand vous avez un cousin ou une
maman ou un frère qui habite la vraie
tendance à venir là ça peut ça peut
aussi se comprendre bien aussi et
parfois patronat qui embauche des gens
qui sont payés moins chers que ceux qui
ont des papiers par exemple et je pense
que c'est une responsabilité
capitalistique dans notre pays on aura
sans doute l'occasion de leur tournée ce
n'est pas que de la faute notamment à
vis de la législation et des tas et des
tas français mais bon je peux partager
un certain nombre de choses que vous
évoquez là où je suis moins d'accord
avec vous sur les conditions familiales
le sénateur il sauf que j'ai été maire
dans une commune qui connaît un accueil
d'immigration important et je saigne moi
même les papiers que demandaient les
familles pour accueillir les personnes
pour avoir justement la venue et pour
justifier de la venue alors j'ai pas
s'il ya beaucoup de maires qui le
faisait moi je faisais moi-même et c'est
le maire qui le délivre et il ne délivre
pas simplement sur le m² de logements le
dis aussi sur la rémunération de la
famille le mètre carré ne veut pas dire
grand chose face quand j'ai eu des gens
qu'ils aiment la vieille maman qui vient
passer quelques mois et je les loue un
studio c'était tout à fait possible mais
mais on regarde le nombre de personnes
qui souhaitent accueillir et les
capacités financières de ces personnes
ça paraît plus intelligent à mon avis
que des mètres carrés et si les maires
font ce travail si leur service ou en
ajoie ce travail il ira assez vite que
moi je refusais beaucoup de papier qui
permettait justement la préfecture de
délivrer ce papier dont je ne pense pas
qu'on puisse mettre la difficulté sur le
dos de l'état de ce point de vue de là
il me semble que j'invite les maires de
france à s'intéresser aux documents
qu'ils signent sur ce sujet c'est
parfois fastidieux c'est parfois
compliqué quand vous recevez les
personnes ou des parfums a priori
négatifs et on l'a recevant vous
apercevez que c'est pas du chiqué
cumbres un vrai sujet et vous parfois
vous corriger un peu les règles vous
donner ses papiers même si c'est pas
totalement ce qui est prévu par les
règles la préfecture parce que vous
savez que c'est un moment important pour
la vie de famille c'est une fin de vie
enfin il ya plein d'histoires qui
peuvent être très compliqué que seules
deux rencontres personnelles peut faire
peut faire naître et puis il ya des
moments où manifestement quand vous
apercevez que ces huit phone neuf fois
dix fois la même personne à qui voudrait
ce papier il ya un problème même si la
logement et même si la rémunération
donc je crois que peut-être plus intérêt
à revoir le process dans ces cas là où
mieux intéresser les agents des communes
à ses papiers mais je pense qu'ils sont
ils y sont c'est pas du domaine de
législatif sur le test que vides
bon ce n'est qu'une parenthèse mais je
n'ai pas totalement l'impression que ce
soit totalement totalement dirimant
c'est d'autant plus vrai que c'est
désormais réciproque
j'ai été assez choqués du gouvernement
tunisien qui demandait le test que vides
effectivement pour c
personnel que nous avions expulsé mais
l'autorisé pour les français qu'ils
allaient faire des tours opérators en
tunisie donc en gros n'ai pas besoin du
tescou vide pour faire de vacances
touristes en tunisie mais vous avez
besoin s'il est expulsé avec le docu tfg
fait remarquer que ça me paraissait
inégale
je m'en excuse pour les touristes
français désormais il ya un test à
l'entrée je crois que mon nom ma
démarche a été a été positive mais je
rappelle que si pour faire un test
qu'ovide obligatoires il ferait donc la
loi est une loi sanitaire l'autorité
constate qu'il n'y a pas eu même un
amendement sénatorial pour le demander
dans le débat sanitaire parce
qu'effectivement je peux comprendre je
me partage votre votre constat faire un
acte médical de force sur quelqu'un
c'est pas l'éminent juriste que je vais
que je vais la prendre c'est dans des
conditions extrêmement encadrée par le
juge constitutionnel mais j'espère bien
que nous que vite s'arrêtera un jour etc
assez rapidement ce ne soit plus
effectivement une et une excuse et puis
enfin sur les les personnes radicaliser
c'est vrai que cela peut être long feu
le sous-estiment par mais il apparaît
normal et c'est ce que demande le pays
d'ailleurs en général d'abord de bien
savoir que c'est bien leurs citoyens ça
me paraît logique est pas tout à fait
infondées tout le monde n'a pas toujours
un passeport dans la poche quand on est
chef espère t et deuxièmement qu'ils
puissent faire recours s'ils le veulent
je rappelle que c'est exactement ce que
nous permettons à nos citoyens qui ne
sont pas en france et qui sont
soupçonnés de radicalisation dans
d'autres pays par exemple des gens qui
sont aux séries en turquie qui doivent
revenir en france
aujourd'hui il ya des gens qui font des
recours dans les pays notamment je pense
à la turquie avant d'être expulsé sur le
territoire national c'est normal et nous
devons ces recours parfois
d'administration qu'elle soit turcs ou
française peut se tromper
et puis deuxièmement nous demandons aux
pays qui va nous renvoyer notamment nos
amis qui sont partis combattre sur des
territoires étrangers ou qu'on soupçonne
d'avoir aidé des étrangers
nous demandons c'est bien des français
et on passe parfois un peu de temps pour
bien confondre le fait qu'ils sont bien
français parce qu'il s'agit pas de
renvoyer dans un territoire des gens qui
ne seraient pas des nationaux de ce pays
c'est bien logique qui parfois ils
mentent ces personnes ça peut arriver
donc c'est vrai que ça peut être long
mais l'important c'est que lorsque la
justice s'est prononcée on puisse
effectivement les expulser et j'ai
constaté
avec vous tout à l'heure que c'était de
plus en plus le cas enfin pour madame
boulet je crois que le sujet principal
c'est pas tellement les moyens
supplémentaires à la paf que l'unité de
commandement de la police
je m'explique aujourd'hui si vous êtes
commissaire a calé dès que vous avez en
face de vous un problème migratoire
important
vous ne commentez pas les forces
supplémentaires que le milieu intérieur
met à votre disposition puisque vous
commandez la sécurité publique alors que
l'essentiel de votre sujet c'est un
sujet de frontières et d'immigration
et donc il y as police aux frontières
d'un côté commissaire de sécurité
publique de l'autre il n'y a pas d'unité
de commandement si vous rajoutez à ça le
fait que par ailleurs il ya une plaie
judiciaire et que par ailleurs il ya des
crs des gardes-mobiles que vous mettez
en plus pour tenir la frontière vous
avez donc quatre autorités de police qui
ne sont pas commandés
si ce n'est par le préfet mais pas de
chance enfin tant mieux pour arras mais
il se trouve que prennent migratoire
yeda calais de préfet il va pas tous les
jours à calais même s'il va souvent pour
commander la police et dans le temps
dans le livre blanc proposition a été
faite d'une direction unique de la
police sur un territoire départemental
et donc j'ai proposé que dans le pas de
calais dans les pyrénées-orientales et
en savoir nous puissions avoir une
direction unique et que le ddsp
directeur départemental de la police
nationale à kalaa dans le pas de calais
il commande tous les effectifs de police
et parfois il ya ces difficultés des
services de se passer des informations
d'avoir des patrouilles en commun
d'avoir des interventions en commun et
je pense que ça peut faire partie de
l'expérimentation du livre blanc qui
vont permettre d'être beaucoup plus
efficace et donner davantage de moyens à
la police aux frontières
monsieur le président peut-être répondre
aux questions sur la sécurité en général
ou france je vais faire le plus vite
possible une programme sécurité c'est
évidemment enfin le sujet sécurité ces
quatre programmes police gendarmerie
sécurité civile sécurité routière une
augmentation de 645 millions d'euros 190
pour le t2 c'est-à-dire pour le masa le
personnel 455 pour le heurter deux c'est
à dire le matériel et moi je tiens à
souligner une première chose la maladie
du ministère de l'intérieur c'est une
augmentation continue des crédits de
masse salariale et une diminution
continue des crédits
de matériel est ainsi l'effet ciseau
jouer avec du personnel qui voyait des
augmentations soient d'effectifs c'était
rarement le cas soit de mesures
catégorielles
au fur et à mesure que des crises dans
la police mais c'est en général les
gendarmes demandant la même chose que ce
qu'avait négocié la police s'est donc
élevée une sorte d'échelle du perroquet
en revanche des commissariats et des
brigades de gendarmerie je pense que
vous témoignez tous dans vos territoires
de vos interventions nombreuses et
légitimes des armes qui sont parfois
anciennes des moyens matériels et
numériques pas évident des réseaux de
radio qui sont très anciens bref du
matériel et des voitures qui ont deux
cent cinquante mille kilomètres dans les
commissariats fin chacun connaissances
sur son territoire et donc j'ai traité à
mon arrivée au ministère de l'intérieur
et équilibrée cela est donc c'est la
première fois que l'effet ciseaux et à
verser 455 millions d'euros pour le
matériel 190 pour le pour le personnel
des effectifs en augmentation dans le
plan des mines du président de la
république est toujours en vigueur 1500
créations de postes dans la police dont
je rappelle que l'essentiel sera en
sécurité publique
ce qui n'était pas le cas encore l'année
dernière et 500 gendarmes en plus mais
aussi une administration centrale qui se
réduit je vous propose la suppression de
postes de 542 personnes en mini station
centrale pour permettre notamment on en
parlera sur la le programme préfectures
de ne supprimer aucun poste dans le
corps préfectoral l'année prochaine ce
sera la première fois en 15 ans que le
mistral un terrain de créera ne
supprimera pas aucun poste rappelle que
depuis 12 ans
les préfectures ont perdu 25% leurs
effectifs la préfecture de la lozère est
passé de 130 à 90 personnels en effet de
l'inaction qui me semble-t-il n'est pas
très respectueuse des territoires et
donc j'ai proposé que tout en faisant
les suppressions d'emplois prévues dans
le projet de loi de finances je les
fasse faire en centrale à paris et non
pas dans l'est dans les territoires qui
ne connaîtront aucune suppression
d'emploi en préfecture sur les masses
sur la masse salariale
je voudrais je finis les quelques points
importants qui vise à récompenser les
injustice réparée récompenser des agents
et réparer les injustices pardon et en
même temps ne pas donner d'augmentation
généralisée des traitements d'un geste
très important qui a été fait pour ce
qu'on appelle les policiers les 8e
savait qu'il avait une difficulté il
était payé 90 centimes de l'heure dans
ce qu'il faisait une intervention de
de police la nuit travailler la nuit ce
geste important été salué par les
organisations syndicales et les
policiers eux mêmes la refonte de la
carrière d avancement des gardiens de la
paix afin que les agents qui sont sur le
terrain premiers voient ces avancements
plus accélérer la réforme de
l'investigation des op j on a trois
mille belgique qui sont pas au contact
des questions judiciaires parce qu'ils
sont partis dans souvent dans des
bureaux alors qu'ils ont la
qualification pour y en a plein qui
manquent donc du coup ça limite les
enquêtes singulièrement dans les grandes
villes et la plaque parisienne n'est pas
simplement l'occasion d'y revenir si
vous le souhaitez sur cette réforme
investigations de bgi pour lequel on met
des moyens de donner un vrai statut à la
police technique et scientifique ce
qu'elle n'a pas ce sont des vrais
policiers comme les autres et je leur
devais ce ce statut la poursuite du
paiement des heures supplémentaires
décidé par mon prédécesseur mais aussi
la revalorisation de 6% de ses heures
supplémentaires pour les policiers ainsi
que l'application de la rémunération des
militaires aux gendarmes qui sont certes
miss à l'intérieur mais qui ont un
statut militaire et donc nous
appliquerons évidemment ce qui a été
décidé pour le mi6 a désarmé à nos
gendarmes sur leur téléviseur sur le
matériel ou changeront à quart des
véhicules en deux ans alors que
d'habitude c'est un véhicule tous les
neuf ans qui échangent et là ce sera un
tollé tous les quatre ans et donc nous
allons donc doubler quasiment ses
crédits véhicule je pense que les
premiers crédits les premières arrivées
de voitures dans les commissariats le
regard de gens en orient en témoigne
tout fabrication française de marque
française n'a hausse sans précédent de
de l'action sociale je viens d'un
ministère où l'action sociale était très
forte
miss à l'intérieur est un parent pauvre
de l'action sociale une augmentation de
18 % d'actions sociales notamment pour
l'aide des femmes et des hommes du
ministère de l'intérieur dans leur vie
de famille notamment la généralisation
des caméras piétons décidée par le
président de la république année
prochaine
et puis des crédits immobiliers très
important vous avez bien voulu voter 26
millions d'euros de crédits réel dans le
plf rectificatif qui donne 5000
opérations ce que j'appelle poignées de
portes gendarmerie police nationale qui
sont en ligne son ministère de
l'intérieur je vous ai fait parvenir le
site qui prévoit dans chaque
commissariat brigade de gendarmerie tous
les travaux qu'ils ont et qu'ils sont
réalisés d'ici 31 décembre et nous
rajouterons donc évidemment pour plus de
trois mille opérations de
de ce type pour les biens immobiliers
dans le plan de relance un certain
nombre de projets immobiliers qui se
passe sous les fourches caudines du
ministre de l'économie et des finances
que je défendrai la semaine prochaine
ainsi que les projets numériques que tu
sens contenues dans le plan de relance
avec madame annie montchanin soit la
sécurité civile c'est une augmentation
de plus de 8 % des crédits notamment les
achats d'hélicoptères et notamment le
meilleur entretien de la flotte
aéroportée de la sécurité civile si
importante avec une des départs de feu
qui sont désormais sur tout le
territoire national et pas simplement au
sud de la loire ainsi que financement du
système d'appel suite de lubrizol pour
les populations
l'envoi de sms sur un territoire qui
remplace notamment le les sirènes même
si ces sirènes continueront à exister et
à certain nombre de sujets même si la
sécurité civile la tempête alex n'a
montré c'est une coordination avec
notamment les services de secours d'aidé
département puisque c'est un jeu à trois
ses jeux d'hier sur les sauts les
pompiers s'est passé n'a que je vais la
prendre
enfin sécurité routière je voudrais
souligner notamment 1,2 fait d'abord la
crise des passages de permis pour des
difficultés très fortes notamment pour
des gens qui accèdent à la vie
professionnelle ou la vie estudiantine
où est donc la reprise des examens
d'auto école avec la résorption nous
l'espérons des délais d'attenté pour
passer de concours
l'examen de permis de conduire le
président de la république dans son
annoncé qu'à partir de samedi les
auto-écoles réouvriront complètement
vous avez été nombreux à nous solliciter
sur ce point et pourront permettre non
seulement de passer les examens mais
bien sûr d'avoir les cours évoqué dans
des conditions sanitaires retrouver
normalement et puis il ya une
expérimentation sur les voitures radar
qui sera lancée dans quatre nouvelles
régions les hauts de france au grand
test vers l'aquitaine et la bourgogne
franche comté avant de permettre la
plante l'implantation et je te proposait
un amendement au texte sécurité globale
au sénat pour que les maires puissent
installer sans l'avis de la préfecture
des radars dans leur commune
on aura l'occasion d'en discuter c'était
une demande très forte des élus locaux
notamment dans la lutte contre
l'insécurité routière
merci monsieur le ministre la parole
madame du monde c'est le souhaitent
naturellement oui merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre bonsoir
ma question porte sur les carences
ambulancière qui a été un sujet que je
pense vous devez bien connaître puisque
comme vous le savez le secours à
personne ne représente aujourd'hui 80 %
de l'activité de noces disent nos
sapeurs pompiers ne sont plus seulement
des soldats du feu aujourd'hui mais ils
sont aussi des soldats de la santé et
cette évolution est synonyme
d'intervention toujours plus nombreuses
10 10 pour pallier les carences de
transports sanitaires des services de
santé de l'état fixé par un arrêté
conjoint du ministre de l'intérieur et
du ministre de la santé
le montant de l'indemnité reçue par les
10 pour ses carences a connu des
évolutions marginal voire symbolique au
cours des dernières années et je vous en
cite les éléments 118 euros en 2015
121 euros en 2010 8 pour en atteindre
aujourd'hui 123 euros
or le coût réellement supportés par les
10 et 5 à 6 fois supérieure à ce montant
nous avons donc à faire un véritable
transfert de charges de l'état vers les
collectivités qui financent les 10
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur en
tant que garant de la cohérence de la
sécurité civile est signataire de
l'arrêté fixant ces indemnisations
pouvez vous vous engagez à les valoriser
rapidement afin qu'elles atteignent tout
simplement un niveau décent merci merci
dumont un homme que kerman le rapporteur
oui peut-être être plus sur
l'administration en tout cas générale et
territoriale de l'état
donc j'en achète directement ou vous
fasse
s'il n'y a pas une présentation quoi
c'est pour ça mais moi je n'ai pas de
frôler alors on va côté des deux avec
monsieur dominati mais c'est la logique
qu un témoin est très bien vu j'ai bien
compris en retard je me suis adapté à
vous inclus karma noyer monsieur
dominati merci monsieur le président
insultes ministre je suis là pour donner
l'état des débats la commission des
finances
vous l'avez exposé au départ ce qui
préoccupe la commission des finances
depuis quelques années est ce qui la
conduit d'ailleurs la majorité
sénatoriale a rejeté cette mission
régalienne qui est la mission de la
sécurité c'est le déséquilibre constant
entre le titre 2 c'est-à-dire la masse
salariale et les moyens de
fonctionnement et d'investissement
si on revient dix ans en arrière
effectivement la masse salariale a
augmenté de 23% pour des effectifs qui
ont varié de 5 à 6% et pour travailler
en fonctionnement et en investissement
il n'ya une baisse de 0 4%
c'est le l'aspect essentiel de la
mission sécurité pour le budget 2021
avec une augmentation des crédits de
paiement de 1,07 % une baisse des
autorisations de programmes de 0 4% et
la commission des finances a prêté à
faire comme les années précédentes a
sanctionné cette gestion à cause du
dérapage des titres du titre 2 c'était
dire des frais de personnel pour des
raisons à la fois catégoriels pour des
régions où si vous le savez bien de
rythmes de travail qu'on n'a pas trouvé
année après année on est passé de la
vacation forte à d'autres rythmes et
puis ces rites fin de travail s'applique
pas nécessairement dans les zones de
plus forte tension
et puis il ya cette circonstance du plan
de relance qui fait que le cheminement
intérieur vous devez connaître peut-être
mieux que vos prédécesseurs bercy parce
que vous avez peut-être trouvé une porte
adapté mais qui chamboule totalement
effectivement l'equilibre de la mission
sécurité puisque nos passions d'un
dérapage je vous le dis et le signal est
de 80% pour les frais de personnel un
peu il y à peu près 13 ans à plus de 90%
aujourd'hui et 10% pour le
fonctionnement avec l'effet du plan de
relance nous revenons à des périodes
antérieures d'il ya une dizaine d'années
où effectivement des moyens très
importants sont donnés aussi bien en
fonctionnement qu'en investissement
alors salah a conduit la commission des
finances à prendre un peu de recul a
essayé de vérifier parce que nous ne
pouvons pas avoir de certitudes
d'ici là discussion budgétaire de
l'attribution du fléchage de ces crédits
du plan de relance mais néanmoins cette
année elle probablement que pour la
commission des finances nous pas
probablement la commission des finances
proposera un avis favorable sur les
missions de sécurité compte tenu de la
de la mission plan de relance avec
évidemment quand même des interrogations
et un contrôle qui sera vigilant et
faire en sorte que effectivement pour
l'an prochain
la mission sécurité ne soit pas la
quatorzième ou quinzième progression en
termes budgétaires dans le budget de
l'état tel que c'était initialement
prévu avec une progression extrêmement
faible deuxièmement il est vrai qu'il ya
un fort rattrapage sur le vieillissement
par exemple du parc automobile mais en
réalité de véhicules quoi un véhicule
sur quatre mais sur un plan de deux ans
ça fait 15 sur 8 c'est à dire simplement
le maintien sauf si on a mal compris le
l'articulation du plan de relance mais
ce africains sur vite sur une année
budgétaire donc on stoppe le
vieillissement du parc automobile
ce qui serait bien c'est qu'il y ait un
rajeunissement il en est de même par
exemple pour les armes de la gendarmerie
qui se retrouvent dans le plan de
relance plutôt que dans la mission
sécurité
mais monsieur le président je voulais
vous indiquer que donc il y avait une
évolution de la commission des finances
compte tenu de ces critères-là merci
monsieur le reporter d'un mois le
président la république et vous en avez
parlé tout à l'heure annoncé un
doublement des effectifs aux frontières
il ya peu de temps
évidemment il n'ya rien au budget pour
l'instant concernant le double monde des
agents de la paf aux frontières dans le
budget de 2021
c'est une question qui sera probablement
abordée d'ici le débat dans l'hémicycle
merci monsieur la partie à moi je
voudrais me faire le porte parole de
notre collègue henri leroy qui
rapporteur de la mission pour avis et
sur la sécurité qui avait deux questions
fait à l'opposé pouvait pas être là
malheureusement cet après midi la
première c'est que dans le livre blanc
il est recommandé de d'avoir une loi de
programmation pour la sécurité
intérieure avec un objectif assez
ambitieux que le budget représente 1 %
du pub à l'horizon 2030 la question
oppose et envisagez vous de saisir le
parlement de cette loi de programmation
java chez le ministre pour essayer de
contribuer utilement à cet objectif il
est deuxième question c'est celle
relative à la réserve constater que la
réserve de police où la réserve de
gendarmerie a parfaitement plutôt très
bien fonctionné mais nous partageons
l'objectif porté par l'usagé la
mobilisation des réserves de police et
gendarmerie étaient non seulement
budgétaire une inquiétude ont tous les
candidats ont besoin d'une explication
puisque pour le budget de l'année 2021
ce budget pour la police est inférieur à
celui de 2017 et 2018 pour la
gendarmerie bien qui est une
augmentation est inférieur à celui de
donc on a une explication sur ce point
tous les cas notre collège henri leroy
le souhaite je vous propose c'est miss
de la parole à monsieur du rhin qui
sollicitait pour une question et vous
donner ensuite évidemment la parole
merci messieurs président monsieur le
ministre il beaucoup de questions
d'image en ce moment
j'aborderai la question d'image sur un
angle budgétaire j'ai déjà échangé avec
vos services par question écrite sur le
sujet des caméras piétons et je voulais
vérifier auprès de vous que la
problématique du lieu où seront stockées
les données a bien été prise en charge
dans l'appel d'offres je pense aussi aux
je pense ici au cloud souverain on a
compris
et puis j'aurais aimé savoir si les
allers retours d'expérience de la part
des forces de police et gendarmerie sur
les critiques on a pu entendre sur la
solidité les batteries des caméras
utilisées voilà donc je vous entends
budgétaire mais qui peut le dépasser
si je suggère madame lherbier encore une
question c'est pas une question monsieur
le président c'est tout simplement une
satisfaction parce que suite aux
rapports qu'on avait mené avec
l'ex-sénateur grosdidier
on s'était rendu compte à quel point il
avait des difficultés psychologiques
dans le monde de la sécurité un grand
stress et je voulais insister sur le
problème des casernes des gendarmes qui
sont quelquefois vraiment dans un état
pitoyable et quelque part le stress et
le burn out de des gendarmes peut
provenir aussi de de ce cette situation
pour la famille et ce manque de
logements décents pour toute la famille
et je pense que c'est c'est un point
important de à signaler merci madame
monsieur stéphane le rudulier oui merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre pour prolonger un peu les
propos de ma collègue
s'agissant de la stratégie
d'investissement notamment au niveau des
casernes et du parc immobilier la
gendarmerie je suis toujours assez
surpris de voir que des collectivités
territoriales telles que les
départements ou les communes financent
de nouveaux projets en lieu et place de
l'état ce qui ressemble bon an mal an un
transfert de charges déguisée de la
parité de l'état vers les collectivités
territoriales merci merci pas de pas
d'autres questions à ce stade ses
ministres
veut un parole
marche bien alors plusieurs questions
ont été posées et répond d'abord assuré
le sénateur dominati tout en leur
version et reversant la commission des
finances
de son avis favorable qui n'ont pas dit
favorable j'avais bien compris de la
politique mais qui vient la vie
favorable des crédits merci d'avoir ce
ligne est effectivement l'effort reparti
comme en fait sur le matériel et s'il ya
parfois des bascules d'utilisation
comptable je vais le dire ici c'est
parce que et dans le plan de relance il
fallait rentrer dans le programme 363
d'un programme écologie et que peut-être
en personne et qu'elle peut ni bercy
auparavant il valait mieux mais des
crédits éligibles que définie par
l'egypte pour avoir plus d'argent grand
plan de relance
donc il n'est pas interdit parfois être
chose facile astucieux et le move mais
en tout cas d'être d'être attentif aux
autres critères d'appel des projets
faits par le premier star de l'économie
des finances et des comptes publics ce
qui explique sans doute en partie des
crédits évoquée et c'est pas fini parce
que comme vous l'avait dit il ya des
projets immobiliers qui passent dans les
appels à projets évoqués dont beaucoup
d'ailleurs je reviendrai de nu devant la
mairie mais j'aurai rappeler que c'est
bien un quart des véhicules pour l'année
prochaine et notamment dans ses
véhicules
je suis ni mme basilia aussi notamment
vous dites que c'est un jeudi matin une
photo les huit ans mais il ya des
véhicules de gardes mobiles de crs qui
sont depuis 35 ans les mêmes et qui vous
êtes pour plus de la moitié changé donc
nous allons même la x
7-8 l'efficacité du temps pour pouvoir
améliorer ces véhicules ou les crs et
gendarmes mobiles attendre parfois très
longtemps avant l'arrivée des
difficultés de maintien de l'ordre
et ils font beaucoup de route vous savez
puisqu'il se balade un peu partout sur
le territoire national demande du
ministre de l'intérieur
parfois des élus auprès des mises à
l'intérieur et donc c'était bien sûr
qu'on leur devait de le rassurer sur les
caméras téléthon alors les caméras
piétons
quelle est la difficulté de la
difficulté de former une difficulté de
fond sa difficulté de forme c'est que
ces caméras
aujourd'hui elles ont une batterie qui
est bien trop légère grosso modo elle
dure entre 2h30 et 4h00 ilité mais la
brigade de police elle fait parfois cinq
six sept heures d'intervention et avoir
une caméra qui ne suis pas là reygades
c'est un petit peu compliqué du coup que
font les policiers ou les gendarmes ils
doivent rentrer leur héroïne leur numéro
d'identification pour que cette caméra
fonctionne parce qu'on doit savoir qui
prend ces images et ils doivent ensuite
la mettre en veille enfin la brigade
s'ils le font des débuts de royal au
milieu le régal pour faire très vite
elle s'arrête et s'il ya un fait ça ne
sert à rien alors ce qu'ils font c'est
qu'ils souvent ils ne l'avaient pas au
début et lorsqu'une intervention de
police qui mérite évidemment d'être
filmé temps pour protéger la personne
qui est interpellé que les policiers eux
mêmes bien évidemment et moi je pense
qu'il faut généraliser ces caméras
piétons sur les policiers sur les
gendarmes mais aussi sur les véhicules
et notamment je ne dis pas simplement
avec une paye son humour il avait que
deux pompiers ce qui aidera beaucoup à
lutter contre les agressions des
pompiers parce que souvent ils sont
restés dans les endroits où il ya pas de
vidéosurveillance installée par les
communes et donc du coup il est
difficile de retrouver la personne voire
de la faire condamner
je reviens à la première hypothèse c'est
avant tout un premier sujet qui protège
les policiers les gendarmes
mais du coup ils attendent
l'intervention et dans l'intervention
ils prennent leur caméra piétons et
remparts numéro héroïque dans le stress
de l'action je rappelle d'ailleurs que
ce n'est même pas digital comme peut
l'être un smartphone il faut appuyer sur
des touches est encore plus compliqué et
puis vous avez
la possibilité d'actionner la caméra
quand vous appuyez dessus 15 secondes
avant ça film car secondes après ça film
mais il faut quand même un certain sang
froid et une grand un grand
professionnalisme pour se dire que tient
il va y avoir un problème je m'arrête
quelques instants je prends la caméra je
mets le meilleur aux héroïques est assez
long et puis j'attends que ça tourne et
bien quelques petites difficultés dans
l'histoire donc il fallait changer ces
caméras qui posait d'autres problèmes
le problème notamment du fait qu'elle
ait un clapot derrière qui se cassent et
très vite
bref il est plein de raisons pour
lesquelles on devait changer ses caméras
donc j'ai décidé de lancer un nouvel
appel d'offres qui est lancé et qui
prévoit d'abord des caméras avec une
batterie beaucoup plus large celle qui
couvre évidemment les horaires des
brigades de police et gendarmerie
s'cusez moi d'être très tautologique
mais ça devait être le cas et qui
correspond à la modularité que mal les
policiers les gendarmes d'ailleurs
j'aurais fait tester les principes des
caméras qu'il souhaitait et des critères
qu'il fallait pour que de la base et non
pas du ministère de l'intérieur du
bureau des mises intérieure ont choisi
ces critères d'apple donc ce nouvel
appel d'offres arrivera et sera
concomitant avec ce que décidera puisque
ne décidera pas le parlement dans le cas
de la ppl sécurité globale puisque que
prévoient ces images aujourd'hui ces
images ne peuvent servir que en cas de
contestation devant l'autorité
judiciaire
ça bouge ça pose à un triple problème
le premier c'est que le policier le
gendarme doit pouvoir revoir l'action
notamment dans le feu de l'action sans
modifier évidemment les images de
critères de l'appel d'offres prévoit
évidemment bien que le policier genre ne
peut pas modifier ces images mais revoir
ces images ne serait ce que parce que on
pourrait avec ces images sauver la vie
ou arrêter une personne en repérant la
plaque d'immatriculation qu'on n'a pas
pu voir rapidement dans le feu de
l'action
voir si tu étais de aussi les t3 savoir
si le sweat shirt était rouge aussi des
thés verts c'est parfois le humain et
parfois facétieux ce qui se passe n'est
pas toujours chacun ce constat dans sa
vie personnelle ce qui est toujours film
est donc d'abord ce que prévoit la
proposition de loi qui permet
l'amélioration du
de ces images c'est que les politiciens
peuvent revoir dans le feu de l'action
des images sans jamais les modifier
deuxièmement les policiers les gendarmes
puissent revoir ces images lorsqu'il
faut rentrer dans leur bureau ils
remplissent le rapport l'une des grandes
difficultés que nous avons
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
c'est le fait que souvent loupé j qui
transmet au procureur de la république
ou au juge selon procureur de la
république s'agissant parlant d' une
flagrance elle trouve que la qualité du
rapport n'est pas extraordinaire
c'est parfois vrai et alors c'est une
question de formation c'est une question
de temps mais c'est aussi une question
de précision
et cette question de précision il paraît
normal que les policiers gendarmes
puissent sans modifier les images revoir
la scène quand ça se passe ses nuits
quand ça tu as entendu quand on est
insulté quand on a des coups on n'a pas
toujours la bonne mémoire et on complice
à voir revoir la scène et puis marquer
ce qui correspond exactement à la scène
est d'autant plus inattaquable qui
évidemment peut pas modifier ces images
qu'elles sont toujours à la disposition
de l'autorité judiciaire
donc ces critères d'appel d'offres
prévoit aujourd'hui n'a pas présumer du
vote du parlement ce président mais
prévoir pardon oui mais il ya justement
des tranches additionnelles
lorsqu'on gère une collectivité locale
un peu on sait quel étrange haïtiens
dans un appel d'offres et donc c'est ce
que nous avons fait ne tranche
additionnelle qui permet de les
déclencher le jour où le parlement aura
voté définitivement la proposition de
loi et permettra postérieur même même
imaginons que le parlement m beaucoup de
temps parce qu'il décide pas l'intérieur
du jour la proposition de loi sécurité
globale au 1er juillet je tiendrai la
promesse du président de la république
il y aura dix mille caméras piétons pour
toutes les brigades de police et de
gendarmerie
et puis si jamais elle devait être votée
en juillet en août ou si elle n'était
pas votée mais qu'un autre gouvernement
choisissait de la mettre en place
eh bien nous pourrions déclenché et
c'est ce qu'on a demandé dans l'appel
d'offres les possibilités ouvertes comme
une option qui est ouverte
alors ensuite vous avez raison où sont
stockées ces images elles auraient
stocké alors nous n'avons demandé non un
endroit qui nous permette à la fois de
respecter évidemment les préconisations
de la cnil je rappelle que tout ça
évidemment été extrêmement cadré
deuxièmement qu'une puisse pas être
modifiée ni de mise sur des saveurs
personnel donc avec un terminal qui est
professionnel et qui ne peut être que
professionnel et qu'il peut pas être en
effet mis dans un club qui serait
étranger
donc nous attendons les propositions et
comme nous avons beaucoup travaillé
cette question en amont avec plusieurs
entreprises jeu j'espère que l'appel
d'offres ainsi lancé trouvera au preneur
dans les conditions les plus française
possible mais je ne veux pas me
prononcer évidemment sur un marché aussi
aussi important sur le point évoqué de
la revalorisation ambulancière alors je
sais coloris ses 124 euros me
semble-t-il lorsqu'on est à dire il ya
une carence est pas toujours une chose
que ce que vous constatez pas parlement
me semble-t-il 500 me laisse constater
par les hôpitaux publics me semble-t-il
300 mines mais je comprends la
difficulté
alors c'est vrai que les ministres
intérieur cosigne avouez que c'est quand
même une question avant tout santé donc
je sais que ministre de la santé y
travaillait à rendre au travail au
secours d'urgence que l'on doit aux
citoyens je me permets de peut-être pas
mais ses impressions me permettait de
passer du côté des usagers plutôt que du
côté du process mais il est évident que
cela y contribue et je sais que en
prévision notamment de débats sur le
numéro unique potentiel sur je vois bien
votre question est bien sûr tout à fait
légitime et l'intéressent ministre des
pompiers que je suis qu'au partage avec
les collectivités locales
je sais que ma santé va proposer quelque
chose au premier ministre et nous avons
bientôt des réunions sur ce point et
notamment sur la revalorisation de
nancière possible donc je ne peux me
prononcer à sa place mais savait
évidemment bien bien compris en tout cas
c'est pas budgétairement dans le budget
si c'était votre question puisqu'on est
à votre commission pollet 2021 alors la
question intéressante
évidemment c'est celle de doublement des
effectifs dans le projet de finance
conformément aux annonces du président
de la république président la république
il a doublé les effectifs aux frontières
mais nous le faisons d'abord parce que
nous avons augmenté de façon
considérable les effectifs de la paf
déjà depuis trois ans 400 381
augmentation en 2010 8 4 493
augmentation de 1000 19 394 en 2020
c'est à dire que nous aurons plus de
mille policiers aux frontières de plus
depuis trois ans alors je rappelle c'est
pas vous que je vais la prendre mais
pour ceux qui nous écoutent serait
peut-être le moment où on décide
budgétairement le moment où on fait les
concours l'ont sélectionné personnes
m'ont l'effort moment ils sortent par an
les effectifs de l'année 2019 nous les
touchons à peine et 2020 nous ne
toucherons l'année prochaine donc nous
avons mille policiers
la paf suprêmement supplémentaires ce
serait mentir de dire qu'il ne serait qu
aux frontières que pour des raisons d'
annonces du président de la république
une partie de ce fonds pour ben brik
cite notamment à calais nous aurons un
enjeu en jeu peut-être moins grave que
prévu soit parce que nous trouverons un
accord soit parce que kevin va durer ya
moins de personnes qui passent à quelle
est aujourd'hui qu'ils n'ont passé hier
mais demain on passera sur une personne
mais l'essentiel de ses positions
frontières seront aux frontières et des
frontières n'attend pas que physique
c'est évidemment aussi des aéroports les
ports bien évidemment deuxièmement nous
avons créé moi je propose ce jeudi a
annoncé lors de l'installation de la
nouvelle patronne des crs d'avoir une
unité de gendarmes mobiles unités de crs
supplémentaire que nous pouvons utiliser
davantage il y avait sur l'ordre public
mais aussi les frontières
et puis troisièmement nous avons aussi
l'utilisation de 300 militaires de
sentinelle qui permettent la tenue de
ses frontières ce qui fait bien le
doublement des effectifs et il ne s'agit
pas de créer des postes supplémentaires
puisque je souhaite que des mille cinq
cents policiers supplémentaires l'année
prochaine
hormis renseignements territoriaux et
des jets et 6 pour les raisons que l'on
comprend soit décrit postes créés en
sécurité publique dans les commissariats
de notre de notre pays et on aura
d'autres raisons de parler devant vous
de même façon dont on redéploie des gens
sur le terrain notamment la suppression
des tâches indues j'aurais notamment une
a annoncé à madame la rapporteure dans
quelques instants sur le programme
préfecture soit notre programmation
oui je la prépare en tout cas c'est la
conséquence de livres blancs
dans le livre blanc et a finalement
plusieurs étapes
les mesures réglementaires que je vais
prendre pas besoin d'attendre leur
programmation consécutivement aux livres
blancs et aux conséquences que dans les
quelques semaines de mal-être additif au
livre blanc que j'ai publié via la
proposition de loi de monsieur chauffeur
imam turki rempli une partie des choses
autrement sécurité privée et police
municipale
il ya un sujet qui relève évidemment de
la négociation parler du cycle horaire
monsieur le sénateur c'est aussi le cas
de l'élire archi dans la police la
réforme de la préfecture de police de
paris
le directeur départemental de la police
dans chaque département ça se fait sans
mesures législatives et puis il ya la
loi de programmation et notamment dans
la programmation est ainsi la fameuse
répartition gendarmes policiers qui va
passionner j'imagine tous les élus de
france est misé intérieur d'un
évidemment mais dont je ne souhaite
c'est qu'on le fasse tranquillement
toute l'année 2021 réfléchir les
évolutions de cette carte importante et
puis le cyber c'est très important pour
la police nationale et la gendarmerie
l'intelligence artificielle c'est
extrêmement important également le
numérique et pas simplement les formats
nouveau mais aussi les réseaux sa mamie
simple aux anciens de rattraper notre
retard
et moi je souhaite que ce sera une
négociation tout au long de l'année 2021
mais ce président donc pour répondre à
votre collègue le roi je souhaite
préparer cette loi qu'elle soit discutée
avec le parlement qu'elle soit discutée
c'est la formule commission qu'elle soit
discutée avec les syndicats qui se
discute avec les élus et puis il
appartiendra au nouveau gouvernement la
république sorti des élections de
l'année 2022 de choisir s'il reprend à
son compte cette programmation qui sera
prête
si la mode ici ce sera son droit le plus
strict aussi la laisse tomber
ce sera sûrement le plus strict
également mais ce travail sera sera fait
si j'ose dire sur le modèle de ce qui
s'est passé pour les pour les armées
mais je pense qu'il faut prendre le
temps de cette de cette longue est
important de concertation je dirais que
depuis l'arrivée de la gendarmerie
nationale au ministère de l'intérieur
voilà plus de dix ans il n'y a pas eu de
grande réforme de la police ou de la
sécurité de nos deux noms
nos policiers et de nos gendarmes et
donc nous devons prendre le temps de
faire ce travail qui évidemment touche
la vie de femmes et les hommes et touche
tous les toutes les françaises et tous
les français je crois que j'ai répondu à
l'ensemble de vos questions et donc je
suis prêt à répondre désormais a
présenté le programme préfecture alors
je crois que l'augmentation peut débuter
les hits et puis en sus d'un tout de
suite la parole à madame kuperman merci
monsieur le président c'est à dire
madame la rapporteure
mesdames messieurs d'abord je voudrais
souligner que évidemment sur la mission
administration générale et territoriale
de l'état il ya trois points il ya
évidemment une station centrale je
reviens pas je suis qu'a lancé il y a la
destination de financement de la vie
politique est d'avis électorale ce qui
évidemment extrêmement important même si
on est dans une année d'élection
contrarièrent 2021 y en aura quand même
notamment des régionales et
départementales 6 parlement votre son
déplacement en juin ce sera comme un
damné 2021
évidemment le budget du réseau des
préfectures et les sous préfectures
ce qui me permet de dirhams en
particulier monsieur présidence au
personnel du ministère de l'intérieur d
agent de préfecture et sous-préfecture
qui pendant cette crise du coc ville ont
été particulièrement et 2 sont toujours
à l'écouté des élus de france de la
population du monde économique
et je voudrais ici les en remercier pas
simplement les préfets mais évidemment
tous ceux qui sont au travail dans les
préfectures et les sous préfectures
alors il ya eu plusieurs évidemment
réformes annoncées dont il n'appartient
de l'ailé de les mettre en place
d'abord le rattachement des directions
départementales interministérielles et
d'aidé y était aujourd'hui hier sous
l'autorité du premier ministre et qui
sont depuis quelques jours sous mon
autorité il ya vingt-cinq mille agents
des préfectures et sous-préfectures et
25 mille agents dans les dix
on a donc doublé le nombre d'effectifs
qui sont au ministère de l'intérieur 50
milles il s'agit évidemment d'un gros
travail est rare que nous menons avec le
secrétaire général
du ministère deuxièmement le déploiement
de la réforme la création territoriale
de l'état notamment le secrétariat
généraux communs notamment les moyens
financiers quasiment 7 millions que nous
mettons pour pouvoir les accompagner
dans un travail de relations humaines
évidemment fort et puis le réseau france
service que je co partage avec la mini
la cohésion des territoires je n'y
reviens pas vous connaissez bien sûr
ceux là mêmes goûts rôle explicitera
bien davantage jeu comme je lis tout à
l'heure il y avait 4 163 suppressions
d'effectifs prévues dans les préfectures
et sous préfectures dans le pf trier dan
j'ai choisi de revenir sur cette
décision de proposer les suppressions
d'effectifs en centrale comme je les dis
et de ne pas les faire la préfecture et
sous-préfecture je le répète que c'est
une décision qu'on pourrait qualifier d'
importantes puisque ça fait quinze ans
que ce n'était pas que ce n'était pas le
cas
à commencer par mon cabinet c'est
l'intérêt général qui supprime des
emplois pour tenir ce délai sous
préfecture effectivement de province et
pour moi ce n'est pas un mot méchant je
voudrais souligner le travail très
important notamment le cas du plan de
relance dans l'amélioration des
conditions de travail
le parc automobile notamment avec des
véhicules outils du plan de relance
c'est des véhicules propres écologique
électrique en matière immobilière six
ans aux opérations vont représenter pour
l'administration territoriale pour 424
millions d'euros et 50 opérations de la
nutrition centrale et en matière du
quotidien le double écran pour les
agents ou l'informatique du travail
ainsi que l'augmentation du budget
social
je les dis pour l'ensemble du ministère
enfin il ya 3
grands sujets numériques que nous
portons en 2021 et qui touche
profondément le ministère de l'intérieur
et donc la vie des français d'abord le
déploiement de la carte d'identité
numérique
à ne pas confondre avec l'identité
cette carte d'identité numérique elle
pourra l'année prochaine être déployées
on va commencer dans un premier
département au mois de mars tous les
départements à partir du 2 août de
l'année prochaine qui verra le flux des
gros événements de cartes d'identité
être remplacé par les nouvelles cartes
d'identité
celles qui naissent du règlement
européen qui nous oblige à cette
nouvelle carte d'identité c'est 9
millions et demi de cartes
chaque année c'est un très gros projet
du ministère de l'intérieur qui va
améliorer la vie des français notamment
lutter contre l'usurpation d'identité
qui est un danger que chacun a commis
sur des lois connaît nos événements
c'est le réseau radio du futur
nous allons changer tous ces réseaux
anciens antarès ruby pour ceux qui le
connaissent les pompiers les gendarmes
les policiers parfois il date de très
longtemps 94 pour le premier nous allons
utiliser la kadji des stages et des
nouveaux opérateurs pour pouvoir avoir
sur des smartphones et non plus sur des
talkie walkie la radio du futur c'est à
dire une radio qui est fait pas
simplement de son mais aussi d'image
nous permettra bien sûr d'avancé bien
plus vite dans la lutte contre
l'insécurité de mieux parler dans une
conférence entre les polices municipales
les pompiers les gendarmes les policiers
alors que jusqu'à présent les choses
sont un peu durs le préfet décide ils se
mettent ensemble sur un réseau on perd
du temps et surtout la coupe du monde de
rugby et les jeux olympiques qui nous
permettront bien sûr d'être attentes
qu'ils pensent ce réseau radio du futur
dont les montants de plus 300 millions
d'euros sont importants pour ministère
en pluriannuel et dont je mène 7 7 7
conduite de projets façon tout à fait
passionnante mais qui prend
effectivement du temps et qui mettra la
france dans les pays les plus avancés
dans la communication pour les forces de
l'ordre sous l'autorité des préfets
et puis enfin je voudrais dire que nous
avons mené un travail de simplification
de la vie politique notamment sur les
procurations et mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs jeudi dans la chambre qui
représente des collectivités locales il
en est fini de la procuration à
l'ancienne pour les prochaines
départementales et régionales
désormais les français pour
sur internet en passant par france
connect pouvoir remplir leurs situations
donné mandat à quelqu'un avoir un numéro
ce numéro servira simplement quand on se
présentera dans le policier de gendarme
combinera dix minutes de temps pour le
policier pour les gens d'argent du
ministre c'est à dire qu'elle voilà pour
cette audition du ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin citoyens
donneront tout le numéro i avec cette
identité
on constatera si oui ou non c'est bien
la personne est immédiatement la
procuration numérique sera envoyée à la
mairie
c'est à dire qu'on aura pu ce départ de
voie postale qui fait perdre du temps et
qui parfois on a fait procuration
larivot bureaux de vote elle épate
arriver et voilà pour cette condition de
gérald darmanin
le ministre de l'intérieur qui s'est
exprimé devant les sénateurs sur le
budget de son ministère pour 2021
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi mais surtout rester sur
notre antenne c'est l'heure d'aller plus
loin
votre émission de débat de décryptage
avec vous rebecca lui resté sur
l'antenne est resté vous aussi alexandre
vous faites partie du club ce soir c'est
l'heure d'aller plus loin
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à tous et bienvenue si
vous nous rejoignez sur public sénat
ravi de vous retrouver pour un nouveau
numéro d' allons plus loin en prenant le
temps ensemble d'analysés et de
questionner